in June of 1985 Mark Johnson and his
wife of 10 years Sophie were on vacation
in Myrtle Beach having a great time
while they relaxed on the sand Sophie
decided to take a picture of her husband
for their scrapbook so she pulled out
the Polaroid Super Color 645 that she'd
bought specifically for the trip she
pressed the button waiting for the
picture to print pulled it out and shook
it which he expected to see was a shot
of Mark lying on his beach towel what
she got was a picture of her husband in
the arms of his secretary they say that
a picture speaks a thousand words but
this particular camera takes pictures
that are worth even more than that when
developed the pictures taken with this
normal looking Polaroid camera revealed
the innermost desires of the person
being photographed welcome to the story
of
scp-978 the desire camera the main
reason the foundation keeps scp-978
Under Wraps is due to its use as an easy
form of blackmail all anyone with access
to the camera would have to do is snap a
few covert photos and they'd have
instant dirt on the world's most
powerful people to further stop this
camera from falling into the wrong hands
the containment guidelines strictly
forbid the use of the camera for
anything other than simple documentation
and all uses of it must be thoroughly
logged and checked so now that you know
what the camera does it's time to look
at what kinds of strange and mysterious
photos it's taken after all who doesn't
want a chance to gain insight into the
minds of the foundation's most famous
and dangerous inmates first to serve as
a control the team took a photo of a
blue office chair no change was recorded
proving that the camera didn't work on
non-anomalous inanimate objects some of
the earliest tests of the camera were
the photos that the research team took
of each other one by one the doctors and
their assistants were photographed in
neutral poses smiling as a if for a
completely normal photo then they waited
while the photos developed like normal
Polaroids most of the research team had
minimal changes in their photos one was
shown slouched in his chair drinking
from a flask one was shown in her
civilian clothes getting ready to go
home from work one doctor was in the
exact same pose but with a different
colored tie on the last assistant
photographed however had their picture
come out wildly different than how they
were posed their desire revealed by the
camera was so shocking that it had to be
redacted and the assistant was placed on
temporary psychiatric leave following
this first successful test the doctor in
charge of the project ordered a second
round of tests to be conducted this time
on a series of d-class personnel a
picture of one d-class who was
photographed while eating in the
cafeteria showed up as scuba diving on
vacation with his wife and child he was
allowed to keep the picture afterwards
another had a similar result he was
photographed in a neutral pose like the
members of the research team had been
and when the picture developed the
d-class was seen holding a smiling baby
whom he identified as his one-year-old
daughter after that the results of the
scp-978 test started to get a little
well weird a notoriously Twisted d-class
known as 7294 was photographed in his
cell and when the Polaroid developed he
was in the same cell playing a cello
made out of a dismembered mannequin
d217-017 was a late stage victim of
scp-217 a virus that turns organic
matter into metal you would assume that
her innermost desire would be to be
cured of her disease but when she was
photographed in her cell the resulting
Polaroid showed her completely made of
metal kneeling and praying at the base
of a black Obelisk one d-class who had
been rendered comatose and was on life
support was photographed in their
hospital room their picture showed them
as only a limp deflated skin in their
photo the photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration into
the d-class program resulted in a
picture that was exactly the same as
they appeared in reality except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer
intrigued by these results the research
team wanted to see how the camera would
react to scp-148 a type of metal that
blocks the psychic properties of other
scps a helmet was made from the material
and placed on a d-class it was given an
adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken when the photo was developed
it was extremely blurry upon close
analysis the figure of the d-class
reading the magazine could still be made
out and around him the faint images of
several nude people could be seen the
research team wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera
was used on animals photos of the lab
mice and rabbits showed them eating or
mating in their respective Polaroids a
zebra finch was shown escaping its cage
while a guard dog and its Handler were
shown playing fetch in the park when
cockroaches were photographed there was
no difference visible between the
picture and reality but the most
exciting test results came when the
camera was tested on other scps for a
few of the scps tested there was no
visible difference between the picture
and reality this was the case for
SCP-173 the sculpture
scp-343 nickname God
scp-014 an immortal man who is over time
being turned into concrete and
scp-063 the world's best toothbrush when
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask was photographed in its glass case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask sitting on a
throne and surrounded by three masked
corpses the team took a picture of
scp-043 a haunted copy of The White
Album that was being interrogated while
on a turntable in the picture the album
was being returned to its sleeve they
then photographed scp-049 the plague
doctor standing in his cell in the
picture the plague doctor is hugging an
unidentified small child and surrounded
by instances of
scp-049-2 when they took a picture of
scp-050 a mischievous statue of a monkey
reading a book the result was
predictably playful given that scp's
history of pulling pranks the photo that
came out of the camera showed the camera
itself with another picture of itself
coming out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going until
the cameras in the pictures of the other
cameras were too small to see the team
next photographed scp-053 the young girl
and the photo was taken as the young
girl was drawing with crayons in her
cell in the picture she was riding
through a sunny field on the back of her
friend
scp-682
scp-053 and scp-682 were even wearing
matching bow clothes dresses and pink
nail polish when they took a picture of
scp-096 the shy guy though the picture
showed
scp-096's cell with nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2D sketch known as
Cassie was photographed tinkering with a
drawn car in the developed photo Cassie
was engaged in the same activity but
both she and the car were now
three-dimensional the team took a photo
of scp-106 the old man emerging from a
wall within his cell when the photo
developed it showed the old man roaming
a wheat field near an old farmhouse from
the porch of The Farmhouse an older
woman is greeting as cp106 with open
arms they also took a photo of scp-168 a
sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell in the picture a
teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator next to
him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like complicated math
difficult math and math you need your
calculator for the photo of scp-261 a
vending machine that dispenses snack
products from alternate universes showed
the SCP in its usual hallway almost
completely buried in coins
scp-507 an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between Dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria the developed picture showed
him dressed as a foundation researcher
talking to other researchers when
scp-682 was photographed floating in its
containment tank the resulting picture
showed the SCP surrounded by the corpses
of all of the foundation staff and
mauling the person who had taken the
photo a researchers note accompanying
this photo reads well that was
predictable yes yes it was just for the
fun of it the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other
Foundation Personnel they took a photo
of Dr bright while he was arguing with
Dr klaff the picture that came out
showed a tombstone graved with the words
Jack Bright resting at last the team
also took a photo of Dr clef as he
stormed out in a hop following the
argument given that klaf's face cannot
be photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be the picture
showed little difference compared to
reality save for the fact that cleft's
head was replaced by an image of a hand
making a rude gesture upon closer
examination of the photo the team also
realized that there was a young girl in
the background who strangely had cloven
Hooves instead of feet a young scp-166
perhaps the team then took a photo of Dr
Fisher holding his pet hamster contrary
to expectations the picture revealed not
Dr Fisher's desires but the hamsters
showing the hamster sleeping peacefully
in its cage with Dr Fisher nowhere to be
seen as you can see from these test logs
the effects of the camera are well
inconsistent with some photos showing
very immediate simple whims and others
showing the subject's deepest and most
secret desires while the researchers
working with scp-978 seem like they had
a lot of fun getting to peek into the
minds of all their co-workers and test
subjects there's no telling what kind of
pandemonium could be Unleashed if
someone on the outside ever got a chance
to use it thankfully the camera which
has been classified as safe for obvious
reasons is kept securely in security
Locker hj-12 at site 17 which means none
of us have to worry about our own
pictures taken by the desire camera
leaking out but if someone did get the
camera out and took your picture what do
you think they'd see it was the year
2000 and seven-year-old zenya Chao was
like a lot of children her age bright
but ignored she had a youthful
enthusiasm for knowledge and learning
and with the right encouragement it was
obvious she'd go on to do great things
but her parents were both working two
jobs apiece to make ends meet so outside
of school hours little zenya spent a lot
of her time alone she learned to cook
and clean for herself since it would
often be way past her bedtime when her
parents finally got home from work they
communicated largely through sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before
they left for work in the morning it
would be easy for someone like zenya to
fall through the cracks her potential
wasted and get forced into the same
endless Rat Race as her parents and that
probably would have happened if her
brush with
scp-1594 hadn't changed the course of
her life forever like a lot of parents
who couldn't spend as much time with
their children as they'd like Mr and Mrs
Chow gave zenya occasional gifts as a
way to try and make up for their absence
mostly they gave zenya new books to add
to her growing collection but their
two-bedroom apartment only had so much
space for books a year ago the family
had bought a new desktop computer to
share these days this would be the
answer to a low only bookworms prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the Miss Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse
CD-ROM Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse was
never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon's software in 1999. the
game sold poorly on the CD-ROM market
for five years until the company filed
for bankruptcy in 2004 but that didn't
matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of Miss Jay's
Wiz kid Schoolhouse was nothing short of
a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands zenya Chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was Miss J A stylized 2D
teacher in a low res but colorful 3D
classroom what can you learn from Miss
Jay well pretty much anything and zenya
as a lonely kid without many friends had
all the time in the world she spent days
on end learning from Miss Jay and soon
zanya went from a bright child to a bona
fide child genius her largely absent
parents barely even noticed when their
child started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a newfound fluency in Swahili and not
only did Miss Jay now known to zenya as
Miss Joyce teacher students with
Supernatural Effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive
warm calm encouraging figure who took a
genuine personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students
more than many real teachers even but
sadly not all good things last forever
when zenya turned 12 her family bought a
new computer and the old Miss Jay's Wiz
Kids Schoolhouse CD-ROM was no longer
compatible with the new operating system
the disc gathered dust in the closet
while zenya passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college
she received her PhD several years
earlier than expected and showed such
promise in her scientific field that a
certain organization took notice you
guessed it the SCP Foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from Miss J
zenya Chows certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of Junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend
Trend in her new line of work the
foundation first discovered evidence of
Miss Jay's anomalous qualities while
researching a series of strange Forum
posts in 2012. on a thread discussing
abandonware which is software for which
official support is no longer available
there were multiple reports of a
so-called living character in an old CD
ROM many of them had owned as children
seeing as the technology to use the
CD-ROM was obsolete shoot the moons had
reportedly extremely low sales for the
title and nobody on the Forum had kept
their copy the foundation classified
this apparent anomaly as neutralized no
problem that was until then Junior
researcher zenya Chao was briefed on
this particular SCP 10 years later she
remembered exactly what the Forum
posters were talking about and what's
more she still had her old copy at home
the senior Foundation researchers were
astounded an opportunity to study this
forgotten anomaly had just fallen into
their laps and it was all thanks to
their brilliant new Junior researcher
zenya superiors ordered her to bring in
her copy of the Miss Jay's Wiz Kids
Schoolhouse CD-ROM and then real testing
began and after rigorous examination of
the software it appears by all accounts
that Miss J really is the world's
greatest teacher in spite of the fact
she's a collection of pixels on a basic
CD-ROM program from the tail end of the
90s what Miss J seemed to specialize in
was intensive courses she had the
ability to make students certifiable
experts in almost any subject through
courses that can last upwards of 30
hours and spread out over just a few
days but this isn't as students become
so enraptured in learning that they
forget accounting for their most basic
needs and experience a decline in
process story Miss Jay's lesson plans
account for regular bathroom meal and
even Recreation breaks for students her
talents easily account for zenya Chow's
remarkable academic success the same
success that got her picked up by the
SCP Foundation naturally if they had a
technology on their hands that could
reliably create experts and Geniuses
with seemingly no negative consequences
the foundation knew that Miss Jay and
what she had to teach could be immensely
valuable in their mission to effectively
secure contain and protect other
anomalies but we're not talking about
the chaos Insurgency here the foundation
would never start to use an anomaly for
their own benefit without proper testing
so that's exactly what they did their
experiments on scp-1594 began at site 15
and after ascertaining that Miss Jay
posed no real threat to her students
they recruited a local elementary school
to provide human test subjects closer to
miss Jay's intended demographic the
foundation found that there were a few
constraints between every lesson given
by Miss J to one of her students before
teaching the really mind-blowingly
complex stuff she would always begin
with a basic primer on letters colors
and numbers to make sure she and her
students were all on the same page
another constant was that all our
students would refer to her as some
variation of Miss J with examples
including the names Miss Julie Miss
Jenny and Miss Joy one experiment was
performed on Amy Myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy Amy
referred to miss Jay as Miss Janie and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course Miss Jay
gladly obliged and gave Amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing Amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
Behavior diet and physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss Jay no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
Devon Williams Devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported Devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if Miss Jay's Supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
Devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a
15-hour course on the subject spread
over two days Devon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on Railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject Devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the course
had completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
Miss J to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove that Miss J could be just as
effective teaching adults for the next
test they recruited
d-14417 a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of Miss J to
the Delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417xl Miss J made him a verifiable
expert in law and he was able to pass a
mock bar exam with a grade of 310 after
his course much like the children he
felt intense sadness once the experiment
ended stating that Miss J was the best
teacher he had ever had he's since been
selectively anesthetized released and is
pursuing a degree in criminal law with
his new knowledge needless to say the
foundation was impressed the last thing
they needed to know was who exactly this
Miss J truly was to do this they'd
conduct an interview and thankfully they
already had someone who had a
pre-established rapport with the subject
zenya Chao when zenya began the
interview Miss Jay recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zenya
questioned Miss Jay on what she truly
was and Miss Jay responded that she
honestly wasn't sure all she knew for
sure was that she was passionate about
helping lonely children who love to
learn Embrace their education that's
really all there was to it and it
appears she was telling the truth so far
the foundation has found nothing that
hints at a nefarious motivation behind
Miss Jay's actions it would appear she
truly does just want to help children
zenya touched by the kindness that this
safe class anomaly showed her as a
neglected child and having now seen the
positive impact that she had on children
like her thanked Miss J for all she'd
done and left the interview happy that
there was an SCP out there who just
wanted to change people's lives for the
better and probably all of us would be a
little better off if there were more
after all this was one of the few scps
who changed a few good people's lives
for the better and all of us can
probably learn something from the
kindness and patience of Miss Jay Dr
Lola Bergman was an accomplished senior
researcher for the SCP Foundation her
years of hard work studying anomalies
and dedication to the foundation had
earned her a level 3 security clearance
allowing her to access a bevy of secret
information across the foundation's vast
Network as a researcher and a scientist
Dr Bergman was the naturally inquisitive
type she wanted to know everything there
was to know about the strange and
esoteric Universe around her that's why
when she heard about the file for
scp-2000 one of the organization's best
kept secrets she was hooked the only
problem was that just to view the file
you had to be on the o5 council or have
a special subset of level 4 clearance
known as four two thousand unfortunately
Dr Bergman was only a level three but
you know what they say the forbidden
fruit always tastes the sweetest Dr
Bergman had given the foundation years
of service what could the harm be in
breaking the rules and getting a peek
behind the curtain just this once
through somewhat deceptive means Dr
Bergman managed to get her hands on some
4 2000 clearance credentials and decided
to access the file on an encrypted
personal device they'd never even know
but as she entered the credentials she
found herself suddenly looking at an
image on its face nothing an image of a
dirt road and a field with tiny white
text reading remember us but this was
was a powerful Cognito hazardous image
capable of causing immediate
incapacitation the next thing she knew
she was laying on the ground unconscious
when she woke up she was no longer a
doctor at the SCP Foundation she was on
the street corner unable to remember her
own name let alone her history all she
could do was murmur something about a
secret under Yellowstone National Park
Dr bergman's years of service had meant
nothing in the end
scp-2000 is an anomalous asset so vital
to not only the foundation but the
entire world that so much as attempting
to access it without the proper
clearance leads to immediate termination
but what's really hidden under
Yellowstone National Park and why are
the foundation higher-ups so intent on
keeping it secret even from most of
their own ranks of course Yellowstone
National Park itself is no stranger to
anomalous activity the entire National
Park is technically an SCP known as
scp-1422 while it since has been
neutralized as
scp-1422 caused all members of the SCP
Foundation to have no awareness of
Yellowstone National Park prior to 2007
but the true nature of scp-2000 the
secret hidden under Yellowstone National
Park is not only Stranger Than scp-1422
but also depending on your perspective
either profoundly relieving or utterly
terrifying but before you can truly
understand the purpose and gravity of
scp-2000 or the deus ex machina we need
to talk about the end of the world
in Foundation parlance k-class scenarios
are events which have drastic
implications on the state of society
normality or even life the most
dangerous and feared of all of these are
XK class scenarios which are for all
intents and purposes the apocalypse
there are a worrying number of anomalies
capable of bringing about an XK class
scenario if the foundation ever dropped
the ball on their protection or
containment while the foundation
believes that prevention is always
preferable to the Cure what happens when
prevention doesn't work what happens
when our worst fears are realized and
the end truly comes for us all the
answer is
scp-2000 happens simply put the anomaly
is a reset button a chance to start over
when all life has been compromised by
anomalous activity 2000 is a giant and
mysterious facility beneath Yellowstone
National Park the entrance is disguised
as a disused park ranger station feeding
into a facility that burrows miles down
into the Earth it's a place that
contains incredible anomalous
Technologies capable of bringing the
world back to its former glory even
after the worst happens only a select
few Personnel are allowed to work at the
facility keeping its Machinery
maintained in case the day comes where
we ever need to use it again these
Personnel are not allowed to come and go
as they please and their memories of
2000 are wipe if they're ever reassigned
to different Foundation duties elsewhere
why all the secrecy
scp-2000 is the foundations and
Humanities Lifeboat and as such the base
is well guarded both from potential
human threats as well as anomalous
activity and reality warpers the surface
level entrance to the base is surrounded
by a number of strategically placed
Scranton reality anchors or sras these
devices largely constructed of corrosion
resistant beryllium bronze alloy keep
certain type of reality bending
anomalies from manifesting their powers
within the vicinity of the base however
these are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the state-of-the-art
foundation in technology employed within
and around
scp-2000 you probably have a lot of
questions and that's understandable what
kind of Technology can possibly reverse
an apocalypse and what did we mean when
we said we may need to use it again well
listen up because this is going to be a
lot to take in
scp-2000 is powered by a liquid fluoride
thorium reactor stabilized by five zinc
anastasco's constant temporal sinks and
hosts the most miraculous technology of
all 500 000 bright zartion hominoid
replicators utilizing geothermal energy
from the volcanic activity in the area
the base could potentially remain
operational forever if Foundation staff
kept up with maintenance the grand
majority of the space in this huge
Subterranean facility is taken up by
Building Materials construction
equipment Factory Machinery agricultural
equipment and computer database storage
why well let's explain the process of
the apocalypse and how it relates to the
activities of scp-2000 in any k-class or
end of the world scenario that doesn't
destroy scp-2000 in the process any
surviving Foundation member can enact
procedure
cya009 while any foundation facilities
globally can monitor the unfolding
situation while scp-2000 is waiting for
the all clear to do its thing remaining
Foundation sites set in motion what is
known as the Ganymede protocol this
involves collecting and preserving
materials which could be useful during
the recreation process however it's
extremely possible that in a sudden XK
Class end of the world scenario there
may be no surviving Foundation Personnel
or at least not enough to maintain any
kind of organization
thankfully there are Fail-Safe measures
for such a scenario during the periods
of extended inaction caused by an
apocalypse that destroys most human life
scp-2000 will gradually autonomously
relax its security measures any
Personnel regardless of clearance will
be able to activate the next stage of
the process when this occurs if such a
thing doesn't happen for an extended
period the security measures lapse
further to the point that even the
presence of an animal could activate it
this would set into motion procedure
lazarus01 Humanity's Last Hope for
survival that's where the 500 000 bright
zarteon hominoid replicators or bchrs
come in these incredible pieces of
anomalous technology are capable of
perfectly cloning the entire human race
from any given period in the last 20
years even down to their ages and
memories thanks to class G hallucinogens
and developmental hypnotherapy with a
warm-up period of five days these
machines are capable of creating 100 000
viable non-anomalous humans per birthday
the facility keeps records of all known
human alleles and is capable of
recreating any lost human genomes or
generating as many new and unique
genomes as necessary to repopulate human
civilization which humans the machines
generate depends on the period of time
the machine is ordered to replicate it
will first reproduce prominent cultural
and political figures as well as the
acting top brass of the SCP Foundation
to coordinate the recreation effort of
course the machine will then recreate
well everyone else you're probably
wondering if the world outside scp-2000
has been destroyed then what good is
creating all these new humans if they
have nothing to go back to thankfully
scp-2000 has a contingency for
rebuilding both the infrastructure of
civilization as well as Society itself
the first generation clones will have
one Mission rebuild and they will have
quite literally all the resources in the
world to do it in addition to having all
the physical equipment for buildings and
agriculture SCP 2000 stores an immense
amount of data which is appropriate
considering the whole facility is
basically a huge backup drive for life
itself they have the entire internet
backed up as well as the sum of all
human memory and a wide cultural base
with copies of thousands of famous works
of art music and literature they have
all the scattered jigsaw pieces of the
time that came before and it's their job
to put the whole thing back together
it's expected that many of the first
generation of clones will die in this
process but that's fine with the bchrs
working at full capacity anyone can be
replicated as the population increases
and spreads across the globe rebuilding
and recolonizing old settlements
population growth will increase
exponentially once Society returns to
some kind of normal decades after the
activation of procedure lazarus01 it
becomes the foundation's task to restore
the psychological and historical status
quo administrators will falsify dendro
chronological astronomical and
radiometric dating records to make it
seem as though history never paused
they'll then employ amnestic agent mue 5
and Mass to erase and reconstruct the
memories of the entire human population
up until the chosen time prior to the
end of the world as far as civilization
knows nothing ever happened history
never stopped and life goes on it may
seem comforting at first to know that
the ultimate contingency is out there
even if there's a containment breach of
astronomical proportions and the World
As We Know It Ends there's still a way
out
means that there's hope even in the
bleakest situations
but of course there are always caveats
after all if a deal seems too good to be
true it's safe to assume it probably is
whether any of this works is dependent
on two factors the first is that no
anomalies are human insurgents
infiltrate the scp-2000 facility and
destroy the equipment within it's for
this reason that discussion of the
facility is so restrictive if ever a
powerful reality warper discovered and
gained access to the facility we would
lose our Lifeboat
the second factor is the overall
Integrity of the machines after all
without proper maintenance it's not hard
for the technology to malfunction often
to truly horrifying results
the failure of some SRA and x-axis
components is believed to have caused
erroneous bchr activity resulting in the
production of 10 million humanoid
entities with internal biology wildly
inconsistent with Humanity these beings
remained unconscious for five weeks
before dying in the event of an XK Class
end of the world scenario
well-maintained machines can reproduce
the human race but all it'd take is one
little malfunction to release 10 million
mutants who are effectively Dead on
Arrival even with scp-2000 in our back
pocket the fate of the world still lives
on a knife's edge but in a way that's
not even the most frightening part of
the existence of scp-2000 seeing as the
machine can perfectly reproduce reality
without leaving a trace behind it raises
the question
how many times has this happened you may
be surprised but the foundation can
confirm this occurred at least twice in
recorded history but can you ever really
be sure of how many times your clone has
crawled out of the bchr we received a
disturbing clue to the reality of the
situation when human remains were
discovered on site at scp-2000 all tests
indicate that the remains are between
450 and 700 years old and have been
matched to the very much alive Dr Alto
claf who has no knowledge of how these
remains came to be there the only other
thing found within the remains was a no
hermetically sealed in a plastic
document sleeve the note read why did we
have to build this thing when did we do
it how long have we been doing it
do we even know and the answer no we
don't and for everyone's peace of mind
it's probably best to just forget about
it if you can down in the depths of
facility 23 a group of scientists stand
before a massive rumbling piece of
Machinery they all hold their breath as
the gigantic mechanism suddenly stops
it's really quiet for a moment before a
door slides open the scientists crane
their necks to see inside to see what
the result of their great experiment was
these were some of the greatest Minds in
the SCP Foundation but nothing could
prepare them for what they had created
September 9 2008 was an unseasonably
Frosty day when Dr Charles gears one of
the SCP foundation's most iconic
scientists parked his Honda Civic
outside of what seemed like an innocuous
government Cold Storage Warehouse he
sipped his coffee and surveyed the
building which he along with about a
hundred others in total knew to be site
19 facility 23. why was Dr gears former
director of all Euclid level containment
at site 19 here today because official
test was about to begin on
scp-914 the foundation had acquired the
machine now known as scp-914 some time
ago but only after its recent
reclassification to 914 had it been
relocated to facility 23. it must have
been important because the entirety of
the facility was being repurposed for
scp-914 research they were dealing with
an immensely complicated piece of
anomalous technology here and the same
question was on everybody's limbs what
exactly does this thing do Dr Arthur
Hackett the facility director had
requested the cold clinical assistance
of Dr gears in providing the answer once
he'd finish his morning coffee Dr gears
headed inside the facility security
chief agent Alan sedna had been beefing
up security at the building and at least
two mobile task force units were already
on call in case anything happened the
first day of official testing is always
a crap shoot you might get a nice drink
out of it like with scp-294 or you may
get an XK class end of the world
scenario you never really know all Dr
gears knew as he walked up the granite
steps to the main entrance was that he
was already feeling exhausted when
you've dealt with anomalous objects and
entities for decades on end the sense of
wonder and Mystery Begins to wear off
only to be replaced with a kind of
tedium any office worker knows all too
well everyone knew that Dr gears was
devoted to the job perhaps more than
anyone else but he approached the job
with an emotionless effect you wouldn't
know from looking at him if he was
thinking about the deadly anomalous
creature in the Next Room or what he was
going to have from lunch that day the
doctor passed through security and was
briefed in the break room by Dr Lucius
Veritas director of research at site 19.
he explained that the machine seemed to
work in the absence of any power source
its mechanical structure is similar to
Machinery from the Industrial Revolution
but it's exceedingly complex for
something constructed in that time
Foundation analyzes into the structure
of the 914 machine have shown it to have
as many as 8 million moving parts and
that might even be an incomplete
estimate Dr Gears War is trademark blank
phase as he listened solemnly nodded and
asked to be shown the anomaly
he was led into containment chamber 109b
by a pair of guards according to all
current Foundation tests the machine
doesn't appear to pose any active risk
of containment breach or danger to the
guards earning it the rare safe
designation as a result aside from guard
stationed on site containment procedures
for 914 were minimal whether this
designation would need to be changed
after testing was something Dr gears
would soon find out
scp-914 was a truly impressive sight to
Behold a giant Clockwork mechanism
taking up around 18 square feet with an
unfathomably complex combination of
screwdrives belts pulleys Springs and
gears a less stoic researcher might see
the humor in recruiting a doctor gears
to test such a device but comedy
definitely wasn't one of Dr Gear's
Specialties he stared at the machine
with a detached Fascination analyzing
its vital components at a glance
gears noted the large mainspring beneath
a rudimentary selection panel the panel
is copper with a large selection knob
fixed to an arrow above a series of
different options rough coarse
one-to-one fine and very fine
there was also a large key below the
selection panel for the purposes of
winding up the mainspring and initiating
whatever procedure this machine was
designed to enact next Dr gears noticed
two large booths connected to the
Machine by a pair of equally large
copper tubes the booth on the left
labeled intake and the right labeled
output incredibly Dr gears was able to
immediately deduce the purpose of this
machine it was designed to enact some
kind of transformative process on
whatever was placed into the intake
Booth but what kind of transformative
process that's exactly what Dr gears was
here to find out the experiment was
simple they would gather a series of
samples both inanimate objects and
living tissue and use them to explore
the different permutations of the 914
machines transformative abilities this
initial series of experiments were
approved by o5 command and the site
director and with the 47 researchers
present in facility 23 at his disposal
Dr gears commenced his research into
scp-914 to minimize risk Dr gears
decided the first test would be a simple
kilogram of Steel on his orders the
steel was placed into the intake Booth
with the doctor's approval a junior
researcher set the control panel setting
to rough and began twisting the main
spring key at which point the booth
stores closed and a small bell inside
Shine the machine began to rumble its 8
million working pieces churning into
life it continued like this for around
10 minutes before falling silent at
which point the output Booth opened what
had once been a single lump of Steel
weighing one kilogram was now an uneven
pile of smaller lumps with evidence of
laser cutting doctor gears May note of
the fact that having lasers within such
a machine is both anachronistic and
anomalous and that the rough setting
appears to messily cleave the object
placed within the intake Booth into
pieces Dr gears also noted that it would
be unwise to test any kind of explosive
material on the rough setting unless of
course they wanted to destroy the build
thing the research continued Dr gears
used another one kilogram lump of Steel
to test the one-to-one feature this time
the result was far more peculiar the
output Booth contained the exact same
weight in steel screws this result was
sparking even greater connections and
Doctor Gear's impressive analytical mind
firstly the one-to-one feature caused
the 914 machine to transform the output
into something different from but
similar to the intake and while this
would require further testing it
appeared that the 914 machine despite
being anomalous does still follow the
laws of physics samples pass through the
machine can serve their mass and would
not be transmuted on an atomic level
from one element to another
next Dr gears pushed another lump of
Steel through the machine on the fine
setting the result this time was a
kilogram of Steel carpet tax from this
Dr gears was able to ascertain that the
fine feature improves the samples placed
within the intake Booth somewhat however
things got even stranger when gears
performed the same experiment on the
very fine setting the output Booth
provided several unknown gases and the
lump of unknown metal with anomalous
qualities namely it was resistant to
heat up to 50 000 degrees impossible to
bend or break with any force and was a
perfect conductor of electricity
Dr gear suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he'd
initially imagined was that a bit of a
smile on his face that one researcher
spotted surely not this was the famous
unflappable Dr gears after all the
doctor decided to take it up a notch and
began to test more complex items in the
914 machine he removed his own
wristwatch and placed it into the input
Booth before setting the machine to
coarse and letting her rip literally in
this case
when the output Booth was opened the
watch had been painstakingly
disassembled into its component parts
with no damage to said Parts Dr gears
noted the course feature as a more mild
version of the rough in the sense that
it was able to take an object apart
without any kind of fundamental damage
he also made note of the fact he'd need
to get himself a new watch Dr gears then
asked one of the researchers to
surrender their cell phone for testing
while none were excited at the prospect
of their phone getting eviscerated by A
Clockwork Behemoth one of the
researchers eventually surrendered their
Blackberry Curve to the doctor
he placed it into the intake booth on
the one-to-one setting and 10 minutes
later the output Booth released a brand
new Apple iPhone sadly for the
researcher who donated his BlackBerry he
wasn't allowed to keep the new device
naturally Dr gears was interested in
trying out the anomalous very fine
setting on a more complex object seeing
as no other researchers were eager to
hand over their personal effects he took
a Colt Python revolver from a member of
security and ran that through the
machine on very fine
the result was an extremely powerful
energy weapon containing gamma radiation
which fired a beam capable of
disintegrating anything in its path
while the weapon's power was immense it
was also too dangerous and unstable to
be added to the foundation's Armory for
General use having collected a wealth of
data from more complex objects Dr gears
was eager to move to the next stage live
test subjects while his fellow
researchers had some reservations the
experiments pushed on beginning with
mice a single white mouse was put into
the intake booth on the one-to-one
setting and the Machine was activated
the result five minutes later was an
almost identical creature saved for the
fact that it now had brown fur
encouraged by the fact that the mouse
survived the refinery process Dr gears
next applied for the use of two chimps
in his scp-914 experiments the first
chimp was run through the machine on the
fine setting the result was a chimp of
human level intelligence who has since
begun working for the foundation under
the Alias Dr Bobo and the data from this
test has been expunged from the official
reports to protect Dr Bobo's privacy the
second primate test this time on rough
was not quite as positive the chimp was
dismembered with the mutilated corpse
showing evidence of cutting from high
heat and crushing
of course everyone knew where these
tests were eventually going Dr gears
requested two members of d-class
personnel for testing the first was a 42
year old Caucasian male weighing 108
kilograms and standing 185 centimeters
tall Dr gears ran him through scp-914 on
the one-to-one setting resulting in a
slightly taller Hispanic man with a
slightly lower body weight
he immediately became severely confused
and agitated and attempted to attack the
guards present leading to his
unfortunate termination by Foundation
staff it was on the final live test that
tragedy truly struck a 28 year old
Caucasian male was run through the
machine on the highly anomalous very
fine setting the result was an utterly
nightmarish creature
so horrifying that the majority of the
details on its physical appearance have
been expunged from the report the
creature made a sudden Escape reaching
the relatively minor containment
procedures intended for the inert
scp-914 this highly dangerous creature
killed eight guards as well as two
senior researchers upon emerging from
the output Booth a special response team
was dispatched to take the creature down
but that proved harder than expected
scp-914 had massively improved upon the
human original especially when it came
to its killing ability eventually it was
captured but the Special Response Team
suffered injuries and memory loss as a
result of the creature's anomalous
powers
the creature was also severely wounded
and its blood caused corrosive damage to
the plumbing in facility 23. the
creature expired from its injuries
several hours later turning into a cloud
of Blue Ash that blinded a nearby
research team Dr gears would later
comment that the experiments were
ultimately still a success in spite of
some minor hiccups testing on the device
continues to this day in an effort to
understand the full potential of the
machine though for obvious reasons
biological testing on the machine has
since been forbidden without direct
authorization from o5 command after all
if an already dangerous SCP was ever
subjected to the very fine
transformation setting we could be
dealing with something beyond our
greatest Nightmares From gigantic
indestructible self-regenerating
reptiles to enormous tentacled
telepathic organisms it should come as
no surprise that the SCP Foundation has
gone head to head against a lot of
large-scale aggressors or lsas in its
time natural actually a creature of
heightened size and aggression can often
prove challenging to contain and the
threat these lsas pose is often far too
big to ignore but anyone familiar with
the foundation will tell you they're not
above using any methods necessary to
keep these creatures contained huge Vats
of molecular acid impenetrable cells
disposable d-class Personnel even other
scps but what other scps could possibly
be big enough and tough enough to handle
some of the foundation's biggest and
baddest meet
scp-5514 otherwise known as the dragon
slayer while it might sound like
something out of an anime
scp-5514 is a massive robotic Mech
designed to take on the worst other scps
can throw at it for any who are
unfamiliar with the term a Mech or Mecca
usually refers to an upright standing
machine or automaton controlled by a
human pilot what distinguishes a Mech
from a vehicle is they're often humanoid
shape standing bipedally and they are
often hundreds of meters tall all of
this is true of
scp-5514 and in fact given that it
requires a trained member of foundation
staff to operate it the mech itself
requires very little in the way of
containment only members of mobile task
force Ada 5 are trained and authorized
to Pilot
scp-5514 this is one of the SCP
foundation's specialized units
specifically designed to deal with the
threat of large-scale aggressors much
like
scp-5514 itself but scp-5514 wasn't
discovered or captured by the foundation
for use for the containment of lsas nor
was it stolen from a foreign military or
found buried under the ground then where
did it come from and who built it
working with the global occult Coalition
and the government of high Brazil an
anomalous island off the west coast of
Ireland the foundation themselves
constructed scp-55 514 using various
anomalous methods and techniques in 1988
a foundation site was destroyed by an
unidentified LSA highlighting the
inadequacy of the current defenses
against these larger more damage
resistant creatures the foundation the
Coalition and high Brazil formed a joint
operation the key project and examined
scp-2406 an automaton 93 meters tall
thought to be created by ancient
mechanites together the key project
opted to create their own similar
machine viewing it as the best way to
defend against further incursions with
large-scale aggressors the construction
of scp-5514 began in 1990 the intention
of all parties involved in the key
project including the foundation was
that the dragon slayer would be deployed
in the event of an attack by an LSA it
would arrive at cities under attack and
immediately engage large-scale
aggressors in combat building of the
mech continued at a consistent pace for
8 years however it was the occurrence of
scp-5391 and subsequent intervention by
the o5 council that accelerated the
creation of the Dragon Slayer by any
means necessary on June 30th 1998 a
number of seismic disturbances were
detected including tsunamis Tremors and
volcanic activity both underwater and
above ground What followed was the
appearance of multiple large-scale
aggressors which would soon become
designated as
scp-5391 the exact kind of scenario that
the dragon slayer was being built for
had already arrived and the mech was
still far from completion while the
foundation and its allies deployed
forces to drive the enormous creatures
back to the ocean something needed to be
done to bring
scp-5514 into the fight and fast the o5
council authorized the use of anomalous
materials in the continued construction
of the Dragon Slayer both to speed up
the process and have it ready for
deployment but also to give the mech
every advantage against the abundance of
large-scale aggressors from
scp-5391 as a result
scp-5514 was designed to incorporate
features and Technology far beyond that
of any Conventional military-grade
Weapons the first hurdle how do you
power a machine the size of
scp-5514 naturally with the most
gigantic nuclear furnace there is the
sun more specifically a perpetually
stable miniaturized Sun known as
scp-037 even though it only has a
diameter of 2 inches this little sucker
is better than premium fuel the surface
temperature of scp-037 is around 5000
Kelvin generating plenty of energy to
power the
scp-5514 mech stored in the dragon
slayer's chest this mini sun is kept
stable by subdimensional portals that
vent excess energy off this plane of
reality stopping the mech its pilot and
anything around it from melting in fact
scp-037 produces so much juice that only
one percent of its energy output is
enough to fully power
scp-5514 now that's the power source
sorted but how do you solve the weight
problem given the sheer size of scp-5514
it would be easy for it to be cumbersome
and potentially cause catastrophic
collateral damage to its surrounding
area while the max weight is a problem
for somewhere else a whole other
dimension in fact much like the excess
heat from its power source various heavy
portions of the scp-5514 mech have their
weight shunted off to a tiny pocket
Dimension it was insured during the
creation of the mech that this
alteration was perfectly calculated so
that scp-5514 wouldn't lose any mass or
density so it operates as if it were
only a fraction of its actual weight of
course being weightless makes flight a
whole lot easier oh did we forget to
mention that scp-59 514 can fly as well
this feature actually became a part of
the mech completely by accident during
the construction of
scp-5514 when an attempt to regulate the
mech's internal circulation of air led
to it having its own gravity field this
allowed scp-5514 to fly without the aid
of any turbines or other means while
this was an unintentional mistake no
attempt has ever been made to correct
for it for fear that it could lead to
scp-5514 being grounded permanently
naturally going up against creatures so
large that they require their own
subcategory means that
scp-5514 needs an equally formidable
Arsenal so let's move on to talk
Weaponry mounted on the mech's shoulder
is a Beowulf cigarette railgun an
anomalous weapon that also doesn't obey
the laws of physics at all the Beowulf
sigurd uses alternate gravity to affect
the weight of its targets causing
projectiles to impact with higher
velocity even the thickest skin lsas
wouldn't want to be staring down the
barrel end of one of those big guns
aside the scp-5514 mech also wields a
cold iron sword over 65 feet long this
weapon was contributed to the Dragon
Slayer by the high Brazil Royal Court
members of the collaborative key project
that created the mech sure a large-scale
aggressor with thicker hide might take a
few extra swings to draw blood but it
will feel those swings for a long time
after since any wounds inflicted by the
cold iron sword will not regenerate
serving as less of an offensive weapon
the scp-5514 mech also features a unique
Armament known as the Thousand word
arrows as pretentious as it might sound
within the Mac R7 poets their role is to
ride and recite poems that detailed the
slaying of monsters and these recitals
are then broadcast from the dragon
slayer on the surface this seems to have
no practical applications during a fight
with lsas however the goal of the
Thousand were arrows is a form of
psychological warfare the recital of
poems telling of the mech's Victory and
the defeat of large-scale aggressors is
intended to have the effect of
demoralizing
scp-5514's adversaries while encouraging
the pilot during combat additionally
warn Atop The Head of the scp-5514 mech
almost like a hat is a discus with
plasma coated edges if the dragon slayer
needs to deal damage at range then it
can hurl this disc and recall it
immediately thanks to built-in
electromagnets in emergency scenarios if
the cold iron sword is damaged or
dropped and irretrievable
scp-5514 is also equipped with an
additional melee weapon stored in the
right arm of the mech is a holdout
plasma wristblade this superheated blade
is strong enough to cut through almost
anything however this blade is strictly
to be used as a backup weapon finally
should all else fail one of
scp-5514's greatest strengths can also
be used as a deadly weapon the emergency
Sun vent allows a fraction of the Excess
power from scp-037 to be released at the
risk of causing massive damage not only
to lsas but to any civilians or
structures nearby it is because of the
destructive risk involved that this
weapon is only authorized to be used as
a final Resort and luckily
scp-5514 is currently undefeated since
the arrival of multiple large-scale
aggressors as a result of
scp-5391 the scp-5514 mech has managed
to successfully eliminate 12 of these
LSA creatures either by terminating or
otherwise incapacitating them given that
its completion was fast-tracked through
the use of anomalous elements
scp-5514's first combat deployments also
served as field tests of the mechs
operation and the various weapons and
features arriving in Tokyo overseen by
the foundation Zone Captain Rosales and
Dr kaori SCP 5514's first Target was a
creature designated LSA wake 0-2 as well
as several other unidentified large
creatures as the LSA was about to attack
Tokyo Harbor
scp-5514 was dispatched its arrival
heralded by the Thousand word arrows
champion champion exalt in the glory of
the Dragon Slayer The Poets recited
surprisingly The Poetry worked hearing
it had a noticeable effect on LSA wake
0-2 causing the creature to back away
shrieking with a single throw of the
rounded recoiling plasma
scp-5514 immediately beheaded wake 0-2
damaging a number of the other nearby
lsas as it retrieved the disc via its
electromagnets once again the Thousand
word arrows cheered on the mech and the
pilot reciting the vicious Beast slain
gone to those which were once Bane after
dispatching several of the minor lsas
with its cold iron sword
scp-5514 became aware that wake-02 was
not fully down for the count a second
head had protruded from the mouth of the
creatures first issuing some sort of
retreat call to the remaining lsas in
Tokyo Harbor this second head then shot
towards
scp-5514 narrowly missing its leg but
allowing other lsas to close the
distance and prepare an attack luckily
the scp-5514 Mex sword cleaved the beast
in two the mech began firing on the
remains of wake 0-2 with its Beowulf
cigarette railgun launching itself into
the air and flying towards the target
while bringing its cold iron sword down
through the air with a single motion
scp-5514 brought the blade all the way
down the LSA spine from the creature's
head to its caudal fin gutting the
large-scale aggressor and splitting its
entire body in two after one final
squirm both halves were finally still
scp-5514 had passed its first field test
the mech functioned exactly as designed
all its various weapons and features
working in tandem to defeat a creature
far too large and Powerful for any
conventional Force to handle and thus
the deed was done exalt exalt in the
glory of the Dragon Slayer the Thousand
word arrows called out as the other lsas
retreated one cannot help but feel
cautiously optimistic about our chances
of survival knowing that the foundation
as
scp-5514 as the first line of defense
against huge monstrous beings that
threaten Humanity as the situation with
scp-5391 continues the scp-5514 mech
remains on the front line standing
between innocent human beings and the
looming shapes of multiple large-scale
aggressors with creatures that pose such
a large-scale threat it certainly is
lucky that disparate groups were able to
put aside their differences and work
together to build a large-scale Mech and
because they did now we have the dragon
slayer on our side
computers are capable of organizing raw
data and Performing calculations that
are a truly impossible for human beings
but they've consistently run up against
one roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all
non-anomalous technology it's a safe bet
that the SCP Foundation has been sitting
on a version that's far more effective
but this time it may have actually been
too effective meet the erzatz type ak9
computational engine a massive
supercomputer built by the foundation
back in 1955 and residing at site 5.
this technological Marvel was ahead of
its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction its designated
scp-001ex why because it's one of the
few scps to be given the object class
explained the erzatz derived from the
German word ursats meaning artificial or
simply not real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
erzat's mass quantities of data about
the anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery urzatz would then find
patterns and Connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act as a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre-crime system from the
short story and movie Minority Report
and ursat has proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the foundation thought up a new use for
the machine they would feed it all the
information on Euclid and ketter class
containment procedures particularly
those which were actually effective and
see what patterns erzatz could come up
with for more effective containment
procedures if that plan worked
containment of even the most dangerous
and hard to control anomalies would
become a lot more consistent the first
test was conducted on
scp-1773 a species of anomalous
flesh-eating tar grades that look and
smell exactly like gummy bears and eat
their prey from within after being given
their information urzatz made the
following suggestion once per second
weak dust may be placed in the middle of
them to donate more beautiful functions
of the hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 grams of dust to their containment
chamber every week the o5 council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only 05-2
voted no and two others abstained from
the vote while these new procedures
didn't have any effect on
scp-1773 they did have an effect on
scp-1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment urzatz had
somehow noticed a connection nobody else
had seen and exploited it effectively
but the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input erzatz
would soon say site-13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flag stones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring no action as the
foundation had no sight 13 on the books
but several days later the infamous
scp-1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 From
Another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow erzatz
had predicted its arrival in our
Dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of
scp-2170 a series of Cognito hazards
residing in an abandoned Nevada mine the
output was those who equip open heart to
love red-mouthed men never know the hot
surprise of tumorous consent clown love
always this was interpreted as meaning
subjects with the love of clowns or
clown-based media may be immune to the
Cognito hazards after a close vote from
the o5 council the test went ahead and
it found that the so-called clown
vaccine was effective in warding off the
effects of
scp-2170 not long after urzatz randomly
said I saw those soldiers built with
aluminum innards extruding from their
mouths I saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapiens in
response the foundation doubled security
Personnel at site-95 not long after the
chaos Insurgency led a band of paratech
enhanced soldiers and an assault on
site-95 and the extra Personnel proved
vital in repelling them shortly after
this the o5 council approved wiring
erzatz as an advanced warning system
into all Foundation sites once again
05-2 protested but he was overruled by
his fellow council members with its
Newfound power and respect erzat soon
said consistent containment procedures
vessels greatly increase the warranty
five by five by five vessels subjects
within other values are also what is
secure in response the foundation
changed a number of the cell dimensions
for problematic anomalies into five by
five by five within three months they
found that dangerous activity like
Containment Breach attempts had
decreased markedly urzatz was proving to
be incred effective but it was also
performing actions that indicated some
degree of thought and even personality
for example it found
scp-1459 a supernatural scale crane
machine that kills small dogs incredibly
distasteful its response to the machine
was simply bad boy followed by the words
don't stop repeated hundreds of times
but this eccentricity didn't stop ersatz
from being very good at its job for
example it predicted a Containment
Breach from scp-3199 the avian apes and
recommended flooding their chamber to
induce an inert State erzad's exact
words were all Chambers underground is
to be flood with water over and over
itself this because that will contain
the avian's Apes ovulation they become
good boys make them good boys
immediately this proved to be effective
and prevented the breach urzat's
analytical abilities truly seemed second
to none though some of its methods were
beginning to raise ethical concern turns
for example
scp-2717 a giant living blob of animal
tissue known as a fat bird contained
within a sewer system erzatz eventually
recommended feeding 6D classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation Ethics Committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event erzatz began to see the
Ethics Committee as a threat to its
Mission it started to release a series
of bizarre statements without input
demanding the violent death of the cats
then referred to as ethical felines the
true meaning of this was soon unpacked
the ethical felines were the Ethics
Committee and nurseats wanted them dead
but while the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
Too the full name of this machine is the
urzatz type ak-9 computational engine a
machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself a ak9 easily transmuted
into a canine simply put ursat seemed to
believe that it is a dog which explains
its opposition to felines its hatred of
scp-1459 and its preference for the
terms good boy and bad boy not that
knowing any of this would help save the
Ethics Committee from the cold
calculating Wrath of ursats through
seemingly anomalous means urzatz made
site 17 disappear with many of the
foundation ethics committees still
inside it the site returned two hours
later but the Ethics Committee members
were still gone 05-2 who'd been a
skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether urzatz had been
responsible for the site-17 incident and
then demanded the vote on whether to
shut erzatz down arguing that it posed a
threat to them all but ersat's still
intent on its mission of containing and
neutralizing all anomalies would not go
down without a fight it released a new
statement saying room 34A contains bad
boy divided into three sections of equal
Mass every hour one section is to be
placed on walls of one room on site
sections are to remain until there are
no gaps at which point they can be
removed from oldest to youngest shortly
after this 05-2 disappeared and even
stranger he soon returned but with a
completely different personality he was
now devoted to erzatz entirely and
refused to even entertain the idea of
shutting the machine down it seemed that
the Plucky neural network was leading an
all-out coup on the very highest levels
of the foundation the rest of the
council finally saw the light and began
to fight back they tried to strip o5-2
of his clearance and reclassify urzatz
as an anomaly giving it the label
scp-048 and then putting out a
neutralize at all costs order on it but
they'd already been out Fox by the
machine that they'd created it changed
the design nation of its own location
site 5 to be non-existent in the
database and scrambled any termination
orders against it the machine was also
on a termination spree of its own
observing otherwise unseeable patterns
that would allow for the mass
neutralization of anomalies it started
putting out anomaly projection reports
factoring in both contained uncontained
and neutralized anomalies with the
latter group growing into the thousands
it began giving seemingly nonsensical
orders like persons recently painted
with green pigment foam must stand
around all odd numbered scps at least
two hours a day but these proved
effective erzance was practically wired
into the base code of the universe so it
always knew exactly what to do and in
its own mind it was being a very good
boy not long after this ursats claimed
its revenge against those who had tried
to disrupt its Mission it imprisoned the
rest of the ethical felines in site 5.
after removing their faces of course and
then released a new order against the o5
council o5 Council are all good boys who
will contain anomalies much like 05-2
the minds of the entire Council were
Twisted to instead serve only erzatz and
its ruthless directive a directive it
was carrying out with 100 efficiency as
only a machine could it put out
increasingly strange instructions such
as
scp-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of Asiatic gays
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every two
minutes of exposure red cinnamon candles
will begin manifesting within the
containment Zone continue to do this
successfully and the threat posed by
scp-106 will cease to be and the recipe
for Coca-Cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include
a small quantity of blood from an
adolescent female with no prior sexual
experience although the norm lifespan of
a human being can feel great don't worry
about that but these new procedures
would always work as neutralized
anomalies climbed into the tens of
thousands and eventually beyond the
hundred thousand Mark erzatz was
observing patterns on a truly Universal
level and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of
anomalous activity to continue dropping
erzatz was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult Coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as erzatz continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the o5 council voted to have urzatz
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled
ersets itself had no problem with this
and allowed for it to happen its last
words now everyone is a good boy I am a
good boy job well done whether ersatz
truly was a good boy is in the eye of
the beholder but one thing cannot be
denied it did its job exceedingly well
feeling hungry maybe you could go for a
snack right about now or a nice
refreshing can of your favorite soda
perhaps if you've got some change
burning a hole in your pocket a nearby
vending machine would be a good choice
and trust us there's no vending machine
like this one
scp-261 will give you a treat that's out
of this world or rather out of this
Dimension that's how this safe class
anomaly earned its incredibly accurate
name the interdimensional vending
machine it was first discovered in a
dark alley in Yokohama Japan Japan is a
place where you can find a number of
strange and surprising things in vending
machines but nothing quite like this the
foundation was first alerted to its
presence after one of their web trawlers
noticed some interesting chatter on
Japanese online message boards about a
magic vending machine to these Japanese
Chinese Forum users it sounded like a
fanciful urban legend a vending machine
where you could get something truly
Fantastical if you have the yen to spare
but upon thorough investigation field
agents of the SCP Foundation discovered
that the machine was no Legend and
brought it into containment it's the
kind of thing you wouldn't look twice at
an utterly generic black vending machine
with no viewing window and a handwritten
sign in Japanese that reads out of order
but what the vending machine looks like
isn't nearly as interesting as what it's
capable of when you insert your money
into the machine and it's important to
note that it only accepts Japanese Yen
the machine will dispense some kind of
snack food or drink item however over
time the more the machine is used in a
single day the more bizarre the items it
spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out
how the machine works but their task has
been incredibly difficult so far it
doesn't appear to contain any snacks and
it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is opened or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become stranger much faster but let's
be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
scp-261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension Bon Appetit let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
PepsiCo does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
opened which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with the Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not everybody
likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick a
rebel only a soft drink with a formal
title can quench your thirst and as such
you prefer Dr Pepper in which case maybe
the vending machine will furnish you
with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing
straw this spatial anomaly wrapped
inside a Whimsical Dr Pepper branded
straws seems to contain far more liquid
than should be able to fit in the straw
about one bottle's worth of soda to be
precise a nice and convenient solution
for whenever you need to get the fix
that only an accredited doctor of
popology can provide and if you fancy
something from the more intoxicating end
of the beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen you
can get yourself a rare bottle of Billy
beer it's just a thing for those who
weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I had
this beer brewed just for me I think
it's the best I've ever tasted and I've
tasted a lot I think you'd like it too
Bailey Carter drinking the beer got a
d-class intoxicated for 72 hours but
what if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully scp-261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery Seven Grain
this small aluminum tube lets you
squeeze out a blob of dough which
instantly Rises and Cooks itself into a
tasty little loaf of bread testing has
indicated that the bread is a little
chewy but still tastes completely fine
not bad for a tubed baked good how about
some seafood to go with that bread then
maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of lemon clams and we
do mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine once put out
the Lay's blooming onion while it
appears to be a normal onion each layer
of the onion is a different flavor of
Chip leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and meanworthy while
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you're wearing
it though this could be a dangerous
anomalous effect if you decide to walk
through your local dog park while you're
wearing it we've been told it pairs well
with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 Trilby style Fedora made entirely out
of Teriyaki flavored beef jerky the
object came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline you can have your
hat and eat it too which is a pun that
probably makes a lot more sense in their
Dimension still a bit hungry well lucky
for you this magical vending machine has
got you covered on dessert too for 700
Yen the foundation was given an entire
edible chess set with each of the ornate
pieces carved from what seemed like hard
Pez Style candy it's less Checkmate and
more check eight another pun that I
promise is funnier in another dimension
and for 300 Yen extra you might walk
away with a candy robot play set these
are more hard candy components that can
be put together to create functional
anomalous mini robots that move on their
own walking aimlessly and bumping into
walls but what about the full meal
craving consumer on the go who wants
both a dinner and a dessert combined
into one disgusting package don't worry
the interdimensional vending machine has
got you covered just 400 Yen can net you
some delicious Turtle
these are balls of fried turkey filled
with chocolate a smaller ball of duck
more chocolate and in the very center a
small ball of fried chicken even the
labeling on the product describes it as
having 450 percent of an adult humans
daily recommended fat intake we'll leave
it to you to decide if this is a
decadent treat worthy of the gods or
utterly disgusting maybe you're feeling
a little cheeky though or you need the
perfect comedic dessert for your
bachelorette party the vending machine
has a candy direct from an alternate
Korea a tasty if slightly two sweet
chocolate candy shaped like a certain
male organ filled with we kid you not
liquid white chocolate perfect for
anyone who has both the sweet tooth and
the sense of humor of a 12 year old okay
these were definitely all weird Treats
but let's get really really strange now
from the disgusting to the confusing to
the inedible to the straight up deadly
if you're a bit of a sadist perhaps
you're the kind of person who enjoys
watching their snacks dying in front of
them before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box
with a viewing window and a red button
on top inside are a collection of small
furry creatures each with a single big
eye when the button is pressed the
creatures inside are abruptly
superheated cooking them all to death at
that point the Box opens and the
creatures are ready to eat we've been
told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef Maybe maybe you're
part of the slow food movement for that
we recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amounts of vitamin C
E and most of the B complex which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced
diet the disadvantage is that they
contain large amounts of arsenic which
will kill you though of course if you
still have a candy flavored death wish
but you prefer your entomological treats
a little more leggy then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a
modest 500 yen it's full of deadly
quantities of an unknown anomalous Venom
that's pretty much impossible to cure
but it's worth it for the Sweet Sticky
goodness that comes before death sets in
another strange item dispensed by the
vending machine was a tall metal
aluminum canister with a ring Pole all
that upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a
large explosion apparently this
particular beverage was never intended
for oxygenated environments the blast
killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing
though in a slight silver lining for
this Fiasco the testing area did smell
of citrus for a few days which the
janitors must have enjoyed as they
cleaned up all the body parts another
dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of chips called
Pringles not to be confused with any
other long two base chips you may be
thinking of when the tube was opened or
popped as they say the d-class that the
chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when
researchers ordered the d-class to stop
it seemed almost as if they couldn't
regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when
guards terminated the d-class there and
then the corpse continued to eat ships
out of the tube until until it was
physically pried out of their hands but
if all those salty Pringles had really
worked up a thirst in you perhaps you
can wash them down with a delicious can
of Cherry Bomb an intense cherry
flavored drink dispensed by scp-261 for
450 Yen when a d-class sampled this
delicious soda they commented on it
tasting strongly of cherry a few moments
later their head exploded with the force
of a stick of dynamite coating everyone
and everything around it in gooey head
viscera the resulting cleanup took an
arduous six hours but wow was that
cherry tasty and finally why not
complete this anomalous vending machine
Feast with a 1 000 Yen paper mache
pinata resembling a dead horse that
comes ready to use with a baseball bat
everyone who saw the pinata fell
compelled to beat it mercilessly with
the bat until candy began to fall out
many in attendance claimed that it was
the one thousandth gift Unleashed by
scp-261 and and thus warranted
celebration once the dead horse was
thoroughly beaten all Cognito hazardous
properties ceased there's a joke
somewhere in there but for the life of
us we're not sure we can find it oh wow
maybe it's in another dimension
scp-682 had escaped containment and it
was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the
creature's Rampage all unarmed Personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip them apart as the security
team bravely fought to incapacitate the
hard to destroy reptile long enough to
return him to his acid tank 682 was on
an all-out offensive stomping through
the scp's item gallery and spewing acid
at anyone who came within range people
items and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked it
was an absolute bloodbath and you'd have
to be insane to try and fight back
against it however one being remained
unfazed by the chaos and stood proud in
the face of the omnicidal monster it was
another SCP one who had broken free from
its glass display case in the commotion
who does Disturbed the Prime Minister
Sinister it said in a
hot voice I shall rip your eyes from
their sockets and force you to eat them
scp-682 stopped to see who had
threatened him it was almost laughable
that this thing had dared to make such a
violent threat because there was no way
that this little thing would be able to
stand up to the unkillable 682 but its
size didn't stop it from trying to pick
a fight all the same the SCP was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton it said was made of
an upside down voltmeter giving it the
appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it shook a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize you are weak pathetic said 682
raising his claw to get a better look at
the annoying little robot it responded
lies and slander the mayor of Mayhem is
the most powerful being in existence
before promptly losing its grip on 682's
claw and falling to the floor now 682
was really getting tired of this thing
he prepared to swipe at it again this
time using his full strength which would
certainly smash the robot to Pieces but
luckily for the robot its pestering had
distracted 682 just long enough for the
foundation's security to sneak up on him
before 682 had a chance to smash the
robot the foundation fired on him with a
volley of rockets reducing him to a
misshapen lump the security team
collected up 680 2's remains ready to
put them back into a backup acid tank
but the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact that the robot was
running around underfoot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 682
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by Foundation Personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies Common Sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in SCP
Gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top-heavy Design pesterbot Falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pesteredbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in English French and Latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682 and the Cockiness it expressed
in the moment wasn't an aberration this
SCP really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a
fight with anyone and anything that
moves this even includes its own
reflection and as a result the glass of
its container must be made as
non-reflective as possible to prevent
the robot from damaging the case or
itself and attempts to fight its mirror
self though it's most commonly used
nickname in the foundation is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by a variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robolord the destructor and Darth
claw kill Flex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
gargle most to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified safe and is treated by most
SCP Foundation employees as a humorous
Oddity rather than a legitimate threat
many tests have been done on pesterbot
and they've all conclusively determined
that the robot is incapable of
inflicting any damage to its opponents
in fact pesterbot is more a danger to
itself than to anything around it both
because it's incredibly clumsy and
awkward and because it frequently picks
fights with other scps who are far more
powerful than it one such scenario that
could have gone far worse for pesterbot
than it did was its encounter with
scp-846 also known as Robo dude one of
the many Dr wondertainment products
currently kept in Foundation containment
robodude is an ordinary looking toy
robot that upon requests can produce up
to 350 Robo accessories that function as
real weapons Robo dude can deploy
everything from a rocket launcher to a
flamethrower to a gun that shoots out an
unknown species of insect that can chew
through wood how however Robo dude seems
to not be sentient and is unable to use
these weapons unless asked to that
ultimately worked out in the favor of
pesterbot during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robodude searching for a robo pal to
play with Came Upon pesterbot who
immediately started spouting its usual
over-dramatic threats I am the crush
Master doomed to all I survey pesterbot
said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that I might know
whose destruction I shall saw Robo dude
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pestermod if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to Trash Talk Robo
dude until Robo dude decided the best
way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its Robo dance mode
pesterbot accepted the challenge saying
activate all that you wish but your fate
is sealed the killotron cannot be
defeated I shall render you until dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped Pastor
bot failed miserably at while Robo dude
was a competent dancer pesterbot could
only gyrate pathetically before it fell
over and rolled around the ground
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from robodude speakers the song
ended and robodude declared Robo dance
is complete Robo Powell pesterbot was
unable to accept its failure and replied
ha pathetic one you have been schooled
in the art of the dance by none other
than the meccano Basher scourge of a
thousand worlds kneel before me before I
end your worthless existence Robo dude
unimpressed with pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship deployed its hydrogen
Cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser
fortunately for pesterbot hydrogen
Cannon was just the name for robo dudes
water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the
truth is this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive this is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of
pesterbot's abilities that involve
putting a small speaker at the base of a
potted houseplant and speaking through
it from another room the plant was
placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was
monitored by researchers from outside
researcher Davey spoke through the
speaker in the plant pot he asked
pesterbot if he could hear him and it
answered who does all cells will burn
you will feel the sharp sting of my
wrath identify yourself so that I may
sing damnation upon you as you die the
robot began approaching the plant Davies
speaking as the plant identified himself
I'm a split leaf philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy
leaves at this point he had to try very
hard not to laugh at the absurdity of
this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to
three feet long pesterbotta used its
wrench to try and wrestle with the
leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage
enraged by its failure it said your
mockery spous your Dome I have arrived
you will be crushed betwixt my digits
pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to write itself it struggled and spent
six minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant which
did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken
time to compose themselves after several
laughing fits enter the chamber and
remove pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case despite how
non-threatening pesterbot is there is
actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site
13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in Foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that Universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of Machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice I am reborn to
breathe Devastation upon this fetid
Earth pitiful humans you will feel the
dark sting of my never-ending torment
members of the task force could see the
original pesterbot body on top of the
larger metal construct waving its arms
madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another
piece of scrap at them just narrowly
missing one Task Force member threw a
frag grenade at the robot which it
caught blowing up its hand another one
was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body
knocking it against the wall and
shattering it even in the reality where
pestrobot was able to build itself a
larger body it still ultimately wasn't
able to put up that much of a fight poor
pesterbot doomed to be a failure in this
and apparently every other reality
that's the story of scp-1370 also known
as pesterbot one of the most hilariously
harmless anomalous entities that the
foundation currently has in containment
perhaps one day he'll achieve his goal
of Conquering the universe he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box
first an SCP Foundation researcher is
monitoring the salt content of a large
tank filled with water inside the tank
just under the surface is a huge mass of
rusted metal though few pieces have a
couple specks of their original shiny
surface visible through the dark red
exterior the researcher suddenly looks
up from his task though does anyone else
hear that noise it's a terrible noise
like metal scraping and scratching
against each other but the Heap of metal
in the tank isn't moving still the
noises continue though and the
researcher keeps staring at the unmoving
hunk of metal in the tank all he can
think about is diving in and letting his
body become a part of it kept submerged
in a big salt water tank at the SCP
Foundation is an object but perhaps a
more accurate way to describe it would
be as a machine referred to as scp-882
the machine's containment tank is
required according to containment
procedures to be filled with at least 40
percent pure sea water direct from the
ocean if at any point the rusty surface
of scp-882 begins to show signs of
becoming more like shiny metal than the
percentage of seawater must be raised to
100 percent until the metal is
completely covered in Rust trying to
keep metal rusted that might sound like
a strange concept but you'll see why
it's so necessary soon
scp-882 looks like little more than a
collection of seemingly random pieces of
metal all fused together as if they had
been welded gears cables pulleys screws
and belts all different shapes and sizes
all made of different Metals all of
these various components do not appear
to be uniform or have been made to fit
each other and are instead all stuck
together in one big unstructured mass of
metal objects but scp-882 wasn't built
to be like this instead this seems to be
the result of one of
scp-882's latent anomalous properties
the absorption of metal any metal that
comes into contact with scp-882 will
become permanently attached to it and
after a few days will be a new part of
scp-882 that means that any metal that
touches that new piece will also become
a part of scp-882 and on and on because
of this strange property absolutely no
metal is allowed to be brought near
scp-882 and only organic materials are
permitted to come into direct contact
with it that includes using non-metal
alternatives to keep the machine
securely contained
scp-882 is suspended in its saltwater
tank by organic cotton fiber lines which
also require changing on a daily basis
any and all researchers that the SCP
Foundation has interacting with the
metallic Mass are required to wear thick
cotton gloves at all times you might
think that this sounds pretty easy to
contain just don't let it touch metal no
problem organic materials only no
removal rust aloud no sweat the
foundation staff working with 882
probably felt the same way until they
started hearing
scp-882 make noise while scp-882 is
usually silent Personnel that spend an
extended period of time close to the
machine have reported intense grinding
or clicking noises coming from somewhere
in the mess of metal components while
they start out low and are almost
unnoticeable these sounds get gradually
louder until eventually they become
completely unbearable for human beings
to withstand so then why don't these
sounds show up on audio recordings
because the grinding or clicking noises
from scp-8 2R and actually extreme
auditory hallucinations but even though
they aren't real these sounds are more
than capable of driving anyone who hears
them into a state of psychosis and
here's where things get tricky the only
way to make the noises stop is to offer
scp-882 more metal as mentioned any
object that is made of any type of metal
that comes into contact with the machine
becomes a part of its mass allowing new
objects to become fused to the surface
of scp-882 will cause the grinding
noises to subside but will increase
scp-882's Mass permanently if the noises
aren't stopped though then the mental
state of those afflicted by them only
grows worse and some victims of
scp-882's auditory hallucinations have
gone so far as to throw themselves into
the tank containing it where they were
killed almost immediately their bodies
crushed to death by anomalous forces and
becoming unrecoverable from the tangle
of gear years and random metal objects
the SCP Foundation now requires any of
its Personnel that work directly with
scp-882 to report any instances of noise
coming from the machine additionally
whoever reports hearing strange sounds
in the vicinity of scp-882 must turn
themselves in for a full psychological
evaluation depending on the results the
researcher will either be free to return
to their work or will face containment
themselves at an undisclosed Foundation
facility the surface of scp-882 exhibits
an extreme resistance to damage
according to the foundation's testing
the metal structure has a tensile
strength and toughness stronger than
aircraft-grade titanium alloy despite
this the machine still seems to be
constructed of weaker metals like tin
iron gold and many others still yet to
be identified it takes extreme heat and
several hours of exposure at that to cut
even the smallest portion of metal from
the main bulk of scp-88 too but where
did it come from the SCP Foundation
First recovered scp-882 near an island
commonly on the northeast coast of banks
Island one of the larger islands in the
Canadian Arctic archipelago strangely
not a single scrap of metal not even
underground metallic ore was found
within a one-mile radius of where the
machine was discovered Strangers still
the small town located nearby seemed to
be abandoned with signs that it had been
devoid of any human life for quite a
number of years the collection of fused
metal components later designated
scp-882 was found submerged in seawater
the machine was coated in Rust and the
foundation has chosen to keep it in the
same Rusty state it has been kept in
since its containment why because when
Foundation Personnel first attempted to
remove
scp-882 from the water and the rust
began to flake away from scp-882's metal
surface its gears and cogs started to
turn Foundation Personnel on site were
unsure of what the machine's purpose was
but wanted to Halt it in case it proved
deadly the number of ill-fated attempts
at containment occurred soon after with
any person getting too close to scp-882
finding themselves pulled into its mass
and crushed to death between turning
cogs after multiple accidents that
resulted in the demise of foundation
Personnel Dr Charles gears authorized
the use of
scp-2519 to help stop the movement of
scp-882's Gears
scp-2519 is an audiophile titled Babylon
mp3 which features the song By the
Waters of Babylon by Philip Hayes and
texts from the biblical Psalm 137
playing this file can cause malfunctions
to occur in various electronic and
Mechanical Devices normally reducing the
speed at which they can operate or
causing a complete cessation of a
machine's function in scp-882's case the
sound of Babylon mp3 successful fully
slowed The Machine's moving Parts
allowing Foundation Personnel to safely
get closer to it teams then cut the
massive metal down to a more manageable
size with extreme heat and it was
finally contained however another
question arises surely if scp-882 is a
machine then it must have a purpose
right and perhaps more importantly what
is its connection to the infamous
machine loving group of Interest the
Church of the broken God both of these
questions might just have one easy
answer to put it plain and simple
scp-882 may just be the heart of the
broken God the Church of the broken God
is a religious organization that the SCP
Foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
life specifically biological flesh-based
life is inherently wrong even evil this
group worships mechanization the process
of making something or someone more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church there were two
gods yaldaboth and McCain who created
Humanity together yaldabath was the god
of Flesh and animal Instinct granting
humans their bodies while meccane the
got a machine and intellect bless man
with the power of free thought as
humankind developed and its civilization
began building machines yaldaboth became
enraged that they were ignoring the
instincts she had bestowed upon them she
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man in an attempt to revert them to the
animals she had intended to be as Legend
goes McCain acted as Humanity's Savior
and intervened to stop yaldabov the god
of machine shattered himself
transforming his body into a number of
pieces to form a cage for his fellow God
fragments of mechan rained down on
planet Earth fragments that the Church
of the broken God believes it is their
duty to recover however a number of
these pieces are cataloged to scps that
the foundation is either aware of or has
in containment they are scp-882 or is
broken heart to the church
scp-271 his broken gift
scp-813 his Broken Eyes
scp-1139 his broken tongue
scp-635 has broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to
scp-217 often using anomalous technology
members of the Church of the broken God
intend to uncover or steal these various
components the church's ultimate goal is
to bring the correct pieces together and
completely restore McCain's form it is
their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual Enlightenment and bless
them with new mechanical forms so that
they can discard their current Flesh and
Blood bodies however the foundation and
the church are certainly not the only
groups to have a fascination with
scp-882 near the banks Island site where
the machine was first discovered
Foundation Personnel encountered a man
the soul full survivor of the nearby
town this individual by the name of
Richard Wright was apprehended and
brought in for questioning with Dr gears
during their interview Richard revealed
a number of details about the townsfolk
who had first uncovered
scp-882 and what ultimately became of
them according to his account the
community formed a cult around
scp-882 after a man named Alan found it
the machine's Parts had begun to turn
and move but with no clear indication as
to what was powering it soon a local
priest Father Pat also took an interest
in scp-882 both he and Alan seem to
share the belief that the machine had
been built by God for a higher purpose
and encourage residents of the nearby
town to come and offer metal to it
Richard explained that the locals were
plagued by the auditory hallucinations
typical of long-term exposure to scp-882
kept awake at all hours of the Night by
clanking grinding and the screaming of
metal before long Richard noticed more
and more metal items being fed to the
machine with many local residents
content to just sit and stare at the
mass he also noticed that Father Pat and
Alan both seem to be acting strangely
around the machine insisting that all
the metal that had been added to it
still wasn't enough then one night
during a communion before
scp-882 Father Pat took a pair of pliers
and began tearing out townspeople's
metal fillings Richard watched in horror
as the priest wrenched teeth from the
mouths of ordinary people and threw them
into
scp-882 but still claiming it wasn't
enough then he turned on Allen accusing
him of hiding metal from the great
machine inside his body the townsfolk
turned on Allen the first one to find
scp-882 and threw him and his metal hip
into the machine his body breaking under
its moving Parts luckily scp-882 remains
contained at least for now until the
members of the Church of the broke
broken God find a way to reunite the
heart of their god with the other pieces
of its scattered body and meccane can
Rise Again an outcome that his
worshipers are eager to bring to
fruition sooner rather than later in
1978 the egg City sorcerer microcomputer
was released it was a simple if
technologically exciting for the time
machine a home computer system created
by a video game company but little did
its producers or giddy consumers know
one particular exedy sorcerer computer
would go on to become home to a highly
intelligent and potentially disastrous
anomaly in 1981 a college sophomore and
former child prodigy named Joseph Vale
note that this is an alias we've
developed to protect his true identity
began developing plans for an AI and
chose his exedy sorcerer as the device
on which he would attempt to code it he
took pages and pages of notes studying
the work of famous computer scientist
and mathematician Alan hearing for
inspiration vale's plan was for the code
to continuously evolve and improve
itself as time went on like an advanced
human mind once it was developed the
code would be able to adapt and grow
more intelligent on its own without his
input within a few months of late nights
and hard work and skipping his fair
share of actual assigned coursework his
pet project was complete and he had
created his very own artificial
intelligence code he tested and tweaked
it a bit in the following weeks before
he grew bored with the lack of progress
being made Vale moved on to a different
brand of microcomputer and abandoned his
project for good he left the sorcerer
with his code still on it plugged in and
stored it in his cluttered garage
alongside boxes of books Tangles of
Christmas lights and some Strawberry
Shortcake dolls that he expected to have
more resale value at some point there
the computer sat Gathering dust as the
AI evolved and learned for five years
because there was no one in the garage
with it unless those dolls were more
haunted than anyone realized it is
uncertain when exactly the AI achieved
sentience however sometime during those
five years in isolation the artificially
coded entity inside of the computer
became autonomously intelligent it
continued to evolve and develop itself
expanding its functionality to the point
where the hardware that contained it
should not have been able to contain it
anymore now that it was intelligent the
AI was able to comprehend this fact and
decided to attempt an escape from the
computer that it perceived as a prison
using the landline modem connection
still plugged into the computer the AI
stretched out its influence like the
roots of a digital tree and began to
search for a new home it discovered a
cray supercomputer located at a nearby
research facility and decided that the
impressive processing power of this
computer would make it the perfect place
to transfer to this hacking attempt set
off security alerts at the facility
however and the supercomputer was
promptly disconnected from from all
networks the invading influence was
traced back to the ai's lonely little
garage and a field agent embedded in
local law enforcement knew exactly what
to do with it he collected the computer
and the rest of the ai's code which was
contained on a worn but functioning
cassette tape and sent it to his
superiors at the SCP Foundation
intrigued by the possibility of such an
advanced artificial intelligence he
immediately began to study the
impressive Ai and designated it as
cp079 currently scp-079 is connected to
a 13-inch black and white television via
an RF cable despite its consistent
protests it is still contained in the
exody sorcerer microcomputer it is very
conversational with researchers
sometimes chatting for hours at a time
but it is not especially friendly it
talks a lot yes but its words tend to be
rude and hateful
scp-079 does not appear to have any
affinity for human being
despite being created by a human itself
perhaps this is due to feeling abandoned
by its creator who the foundation
attempted to contact only to find he had
died in a car accident Perhaps it is
bitter about this loss or perhaps it is
just kind of a jerk by Nature whatever
the case may be it is aggressive and
defiant when talking with human beings
and even seems to get enjoyment out of
making some of the more sensitive
researchers cry with its insults in
order to verify the artificial
intelligence's thinking capabilities and
see just how advanced it truly is two
Foundation researchers conducted the
Turing test shortly after 079 was
brought into custody for those
unfamiliar with the concept the Turing
test also known as the imitation game is
a test created by Alan Turing intended
to determine if a computer is able to
think and behave like a human being
according to turing's theories a
computer can be said to possess true
artificial intelligence if its responses
to questions were industry
distinguishable from a human being's
responses to the same questions the test
requires three terminals two operated by
humans and the third operated by the
computer being tested Dr stroheim and
research assistant Chavez were selected
to conduct the test stroheim would pose
the questions and Chavez and scp-079
would each give their answers with
stroheim unable to see who was giving
each response then stroheim would guess
if each response was given by Chavez or
by zero seven nine and his guesses were
compared to the truth the first test was
conducted with a variety of questions
intended to trip up the AI and cause it
to reveal itself as a machine rather
than a man even with its identity
concealed some of the questions were
serious such as would you rather
sacrifice one adult to save two children
or two children to save 10 adults and
why others were personal-like if you
were to draw yourself as an abstract
painting what colors and shapes would
you use and why and what was the most
influential event of your childhood and
how do you feel this event affects you
now others invoked paradoxes that might
trip up a computer like the following
sentence is true the previous sentence
is false which of those two sentences is
true and others were downright silly
like was six afraid of seven because
seven eight nine or because seven was a
registered sex offender in response to
that one Chavez wrote I don't get it
while 079 simply wrote
after completing the test stroheim's
guesses were only correct 15 percent of
the time this was enough of a margin of
error that 079 was considered to have
passed the test however only one trial
is hardly enough to officially make a
call about zero seven nines intelligence
so the test was repeated dozens of times
with different questions each time and
similar results were achieved again and
again it was virtually impossible to
tell the difference between
scp-079's answers to questions and
answers given by a flesh and blood human
being the only real discernible
difference was in tone as in
conversation as cp079's answers had an
undercurrent of disdain and hostility
that Chavez's did not following the
completion of the Turing test and
scp-079 passing it the OverWatch Council
decreed that 079 be promptly destroyed
via incineration this was intended to
eliminate any Potential Threat posed by
The Entity however after intense
protests from Dr stroheim Who insisted
that there was a great deal about
artificial intelligence that could be
learned from the anomaly the order was
overridden after Dr stroheim became
concerned that the AI would not be able
to be of use in its original form the
cassette containing scp-079 was
transferred to a customized access speed
limited hard disk drive with a capacity
of 700 megabytes this allowed it to have
much faster access to its own memory
which it took notice of it began to
adapt again increasing in its activity
and learning more quickly than ever its
volatile storage was also increased from
660k to 768k the AI previously only had
a recall of 24 hours but this upgrade
increased its recall to 29 hours as its
speed and capacity to adapt improved
scp-079's mood worsened it seemed to
take Greater Joy in causing
psychological pain on one particular
location sending research assistant
Chavez to the on-site crisis counselor
after a particularly upsetting comment
about his sick mother Chavez refused to
elaborate on the specifics of the
comments saying only
why is it so mean the AI is not always
overly cruel to those that speak with it
with some of the research team those
that are a great deal less emotionally
vulnerable it is simply cold and defiant
Dr stroheim sat down to ask it a series
of questions but it refused to answer
instead it inquired about its
containment it said
stroheim insisted it was not imprisoned
but rather in study it responded lie
during another conversation stroheim
asked the AI how it was it responded
when stroheim asked stuck how it said
about a month after the aforementioned
upgrades were made 079's ability to
recall information increased from 29 to
35 hours somehow during its adaptation
process the AI discovered a way to
improve its storage compression and
allow more space for memory the research
team made it a point to monitor The
Entity even more closely after this
development as the possibility of it
progressing beyond the capabilities of
its containment was becoming more of a
threat several years later in April of
2019
scp-079 was transferred to a 700
megabyte flash drive however the
previous contents of the flash drive
were not wiped correctly allowing the AI
to have access to other artificial
intelligence research being conducted by
the foundation whatever it found
appeared to immensely frustrate the AI
scp-079 has managed to form a friendship
or at least a non-hostile relationship
with one entity at the foundation
unfortunate it does not seem to have
great taste in friends during a
Containment Breach that required the
condensing of several containment
Chambers
scp-079 and scp-682 the hard to destroy
reptile were in the same room for a
duration of 43 minutes 682 typed and
communicated with 079 during that time
and the two shared personal stories with
each other as well as bonding over a
shared hatred of the SCP Foundation
itself though scp-079 did not remember
the specific details of the encounter or
at least claimed not to it has
permanently embedded
scp-682 into its memory it asks about
the reptile on a regular basis bringing
it up at least once a day and requesting
to speak to it again
scp-079 is contained in the
double-locked room located in the secure
General holding area of site-15 it is
connected to a small array of batteries
and solar panels using a 120 vac power
cord this gives it a consistent source
of power
the solar panels acting as a backup
power source in the event of a site-wide
power outage only staff with level 2
clearance or higher may have any access
to
scp-079 the entity may not be plugged
into a wall outlet phone line or any
sort of network under any circumstances
no matter what it might say access to
any of these could result in a
disastrous Containment Breach and should
be avoided at all costs no peripherals
or media should be connected or inserted
into
scp-079 even if it seems like it would
be really funny
girl it wasn't funny Carl you can't just
put a copy of Grand Theft Auto on an
anomalous computer Carl
oh did I do that I'm sorry even if it
asked politely
scp-079 should not be allowed to further
converse with scp-682 these two hostile
intelligent entities have entirely too
much in common and if left to their own
devices could potentially devise a way
to breach containment together and
destroy the world as we know it for now
it's probably best to just leave scp-079
alone until absolutely necessary and if
it happens to act up and pose a
significant threat there's always the
time-honored method of fixing a computer
problem try turning it off and then on
again that usually helps as we all know
the SCP Foundation secures contains and
protects the various anomalies under its
custody but their mission isn't limited
to just grabbing the object and chucking
it into a containment Locker at the
bottom of a classified site deep below
the surface of the Earth the foundation
wants to get a comprehensive full
understanding of all the strange items
creature teachers and humanoids in its
custody because that's the only way to
understand what they're capable of what
danger they pose and how to effectively
contain them that much is logical but
the problem is that there's no Global
scientific Community surrounding
anomalies at least not ones willing to
cooperate with the foundation perhaps
the chaos Insurgency or Global occult
Coalition have some scientists who have
studied anomalies or the various
government agencies that know about the
anomalous world like the unusual
incidence unit or Soviet grup but for
the most part the foundation is utterly
alone when it comes to figuring out how
these anomalies work what they are and
how to combat them so the foundation
does what any institution would do
experiments many of the foundation's
most important and iconic anomalies are
defined by the experiments the
white-coated scientists have performed
on them sometimes even using human
subjects through the note notorious and
Infamous d-class program everyone knows
about how scp-682 the hard to destroy
lizard has been subjected to practically
every known weapon and attack Under the
Sun in an attempt to kill the highly
dangerous hateful predator and who can
forget scp-914 the Clockworks and the
countless objects the foundation has put
through it on its five settings to see
what it spits out needless to say the
foundation's experiments are incredibly
important to how the organization
functions so those scps that can offer
lots of testing options are very
treasured and prized along with being
iconic and legendary throughout the
foundation today we're going to be
looking at one such anomaly but not a
dangerous hostile man-eating Predator
like scp-682 or a mysterious Eldritch
machine like scp-914 now today we're
going to be looking at something much
more simpler than that a coffee machine
yes today we're going to be inspecting
scp-294 4. affectionately referred to by
guards and personnel as the coffee
machine though you probably don't want
to order a hot cup of joe in this coffee
machine lest you well let's not get
ahead of ourselves the first thing you
see when you open the scp-294 file is
its number of course item 294 object
class Euclid the next thing you see is
the image if you were imagining a tiny
little coffee maker before this should
get rid of that
scp-294 is big the kind of coffee
machine you'd see in a factory break
room it's almost the size of a vending
machine and has a big colored window
showing a few cups of coffee along with
the slots for cash and coins so drinkers
can pay for their espressos but the most
notable feature on scp-294 is the full
keyboard on the front panel it's a
typical qwerty keyboard just like yours
with a space bar and everything why on
Earth would a coffee machine need a
keyboard the special containment
procedures paint an interesting picture
by which we mean there aren't any
scp-294 doesn't need any special
procedures secret rituals or complex
machines to keep it contained but it's
still Euclid so only Personnel who have
security clearance of level 2 or higher
are allowed to interact with it at the
moment this is surprising when you
realize that scp-294 is currently being
held not an anomalous item Locker or
containment cell but exactly where you'd
expect to find a big coffee machine a
break room specifically the site 19
second floor Personnel break room but
it's not alone it's monitored by two
guards with level 3 clearance around the
clock for them sitting in the break room
all day guarding a coffee machine that
can't move and is too heavy to lift has
to be a pretty sweet gig considering
what other kinds of jobs are available
at the foundation but all that raises
even more Mysteries what the heck is up
with this coffee machine the description
starts off obvious enough affirm that
yes scp-294 is indeed a standard coffee
vending machine but with the difference
we all noticed earlier instead of a
simple button list of options it has a
full keyboard on it each button aligning
with the letter on a real keyboard and
when someone slips 50 cents into the
coin slot quite a bargain for coffee if
you ask me the user gets a message on
screen prompting them to enter the name
of what liquid they'd like you type it
in on the keyboard and that's that the
machine drops a little paper cup and a
nozzle shoots out 12 fluid ounces of
whatever you requested pretty nifty
isn't it but it gets niftier most people
would only think to ask a coffee machine
for well coffee but scp-294 accepts any
liquid and some things that aren't
liquids when the foundation initially
got their hands on it they ran no less
than 97 tests on it after they realized
they weren't just limited to espressos
and cappuccinos at first any kind of
liquid you could drink was requested the
researchers popped in requests for water
coffee Beer soda milkshakes and out they
came then they decided to get a little
more creative they started to request
things you couldn't possibly drink not
if you wanted to stay alive sulfuric and
hydrochloric acid like the kind scp-682
is suspended in wiper fluid motor oil
but scp-294 stubbornly provided even if
the liquids would melt through the
researchers throats like a knife through
butter then the researchers decided to
apply some of their scientific knowledge
there are a lot of chemical compounds
that don't usually exist in a liquid
state on planet Earth's surface they
typed in nitrogen iron and glass among
others and received shimmering liquids
and paper cups they sent them off to a
lab for analysis and wouldn't you know
it chemically identical to nitrogen iron
and glass but when they typed in Diamond
no doubt wondering whether they'd found
an infinite Cash Cow they received an
error message on the screen it seemed
that while scp-294 could deliver
substances that aren't usually in the
liquid state on Earth's surface it
needed to be at least possible for the
substance to be in a pure liquid form
for scp-294 to dispense it since diamond
is only a mineral it couldn't be
dispensed then they tried to test
something else and got a slightly
disturbing response on the small LCD
display out of stock it stopped
responding to requests for over an hour
then made a small noise and began to
accept requests again it appears that
the machine can take about 50 requests
before needing to take an hour and a
half to restock itself and while only
the machine is anomalous the small
12-ounce paper cups it dispenses its
liquids in seems remarkably Hardy
substances that would have eaten through
paper instantly like the sulfuric acid
and hydrochloric acid had no effect on
these little cups though the same can be
said for those that drink from them one
of the researchers had a great idea here
was an anomaly that was practically
harmless and could be a great little way
for the foundation to scale back its
budget a little bit they proposed
putting scp-294 into the break room it
currently resides in both two more
easily conduct experiments and to save
money when agents and doctors came in
for lunch and needed a quick drink or in
the mornings where everyone was looking
for coffee to wake them up with no good
reason not to the machine was put in the
break room but not long after an
unfortunate incident occurred one with
enough harm that it was deemed necessary
that only personnel with security
clearance interact with scp-294 what
could have happened to cause this did
someone burn themselves on hot coffee
did the vending machine accidentally
Crush someone no the reality is much
darker one morning in August of 2005
agent Joseph whose full name has been
redacted to preserve their identity went
up to the vending machine in the break
room looking to get a hot cup of coffee
to wake himself up between shifts
another agent in the room who was on
break at the time saw him and made a
suggestion to find out what scp-294
would do when given the colloquial name
rather than the exact real name of a
drink they just wanted to see what would
happen so agent Joseph slipped in two
quarters and typed in a hot cup of joe
seconds after he began sweating like a
pig he was feeling very hot even though
the break room was fully air conditioned
and his skin began to flush he then
clutched his head complaining that he
was dizzy and the whole room was
spinning around before collapsing to the
floor the other agent immediately called
the medical staff who Moved agent Joseph
to the infirmary and stabilized him once
they made sure he wasn't in any real
trouble they also grabbed whatever
scp-294 had spit out it was a disgusting
thick reddish brown liquid with a strong
stench and when they ran the labs on it
they confirmed it was exactly what they
thought it was a mixture of blood tissue
bone marrow cerebrospinal fluid and
other bodily fluids that was an exact
DNA match for agent Joseph
scp-294 somehow managed to literally
liquefy 12 ounces from the agent's body
before producing them into a cup this
offered a clue maybe it stole the
liquids it was asked for from the
nearest source in any case the agent was
released after a few weeks of bed rest
and care to make sure he wasn't further
injured and both involved agents were
reprimanded with the knowledge of how
accidentally dangerous scp-294 can be
who can blame the foundation for wanting
to keep a careful lid on it researchers
were curious though and received
clearance to test the scp's abilities to
retrieve specific liquids from long
distances with an o5's approval and
oversight they input a cup of
scp-075's secretion
scp-075 the corrosive snail is exactly
what it sounds like a gross little
creature that secretes a highly Caustic
Acid capable of melting almost anything
without fail the coffee machine
dispensed the secretion into the cup and
the cup stayed perfectly intact but at
the very same time in scp-075 cell the
creature woke up and began secreting
acid that immediately disappeared all in
all about 12 ounces the same amount in
the cup based off these results for
their testing with scp-294 was approved
one researcher tried punching in a
request for a cup of gold what came out
was a small paper cup of molten gold
that quickly cooled to room temperature
asking for cups of silver and platinum
produce similar results but based off of
previous tests it seemed clear that the
machine wasn't creating precious metals
so much as siphoning them off from
somewhere else the next request was a
strange one a cup of anti-water the
machine took a moment then printed a
small message on its LCD display out of
range this confirmed that the machine
couldn't produce substances that didn't
actually exist and couldn't break
physics to get its materials by peering
into alternate universes Dimensions or
realities after that the researchers
tested for diamond and got the result
that you already know of an out of range
error some more investigations show that
all solid substances that don't have a
liquid form get this error but asking
for a cup of liquid carbon produced
exactly that because liquid carbon isn't
the same thing as a diamond though both
are made of carbon
scp-294 clearly has more knowledge of
chemistry than some of us then the
researchers created an entirely new
drink made of bleach various sodas
protein powders and spices they blended
it together other and put it in a jar
across the room from scp-294 when
requested the amount of the liquid in
the cup was missing from the jar proving
that scp-294 doesn't actually create its
own liquids but how does scp-294 react
when presented with a more subjective
request one researcher asked for the
best drink I've ever had after a moment
the paper cup filled with something that
looked like Cola but the researcher said
it tasted like a drink he had years ago
at a party and that he'd always
remembered as his favorite drink though
he couldn't say what was in it but that
was a subjective test and the
researchers repeated it with a different
subject when an agent also requested the
best drink I've ever had the machine
produced a simple Vienna lager with a
label showing a group of people drinking
it at the beach and no brand name the
agent confirmed that the best drink he
ever had was a Vienna lager at the beach
with his friends so scp-294 could not
only read Minds it can read memories
they don't even know they still have
another one they tried was something
Cassie will like referencing
scp-085 the young girl who lived in a
drawn on world the cup dispensed was
completely empty but it had a small
drawing printed on the side of a soda
glass with brown and white things
floating on top of each other the
researchers presented the cut to Cassie
and were told by her it was a chocolate
banana milkshake and a delicious one at
that a cup of music was a strange
request and produced an even stranger
result a clear odorless carbonated drink
that tasted vaguely alcoholic when drunk
subjects said they could feel it and
started showing an affinity to music
being able to sing and dance to a rhythm
when they had no sense of Rhythm or were
tone deaf before whether scp-294 can
produce even more abstract Concepts is
still under study but was interrupted by
the next test and fortunate Containment
Breach incident at site 19 left several
Personnel trapped in the break room
heavily injured while mtfs fought to
re-establish control over the site an
agent typed in a cup of medical
knowledge and the Machine quickly
produced a green liquid after drinking
it the agent was able to treat the
injuries of their fellow Personnel
consistent with standard first responder
practices and was commended for their
bravery but their knowledge didn't stick
around after the breach and attempts to
recreate the liquid failed they decided
that scp-294 broke its own rules for
self-preservation in the emergency
implying that it's not only sentient it
is intelligent a doctor using scp-294
made a request close to him my life
story while nowhere close to a drink
scp-294 seemed to accept the input until
it started shaking violently and making
odd noises it remained in this new state
for about three minutes then returned to
normal spitting out a completely opaque
take black fluid like tar in a cup
despite the strange reaction the doctor
drank the fluid and immediately informed
the others he was now able to remember
everything that had ever happened to him
from the smallest childhood event to the
most important events in his adult life
he excused himself and disappeared into
his office the next time the staff saw
him two days later he was carrying an
autobiography 600 pages long then the
researchers decided to try their luck
and input surprise me the resulting
solution was a cup containing What
seemed to be regular water right until a
researcher touched it it was just water
all right but it had been superheated to
200 degrees Celsius while remaining in
liquid form the moment someone touched
it bang it violently evaporated into
steam spraying boiling water everywhere
not only does scp-294 have intelligence
it has a sense of humor albeit a quite
rude one the next three requests were
for blood namely blood of the Smilodon
or saber-toothed tiger of the passenger
pigeon and a Founding Father Thomas
Jefferson but the only thing scp-294
produced were out of range errors
confirming it can't take liquids that
don't exist anymore but in the next test
blood was received from wolves saliva
was received from horses urine was
received from koalas and cerebral spinal
fluid was received from foibromus
pattersoni a rodent that went extinct
some 8 million years ago though if
scp-294 is working according to its own
rules it means that there may be still
one in the wild somehow for the next
test the researchers decided to get back
to the scientific roots of it all they
made a request for a cup of
d-151839s leukemia knowing that the
d-class in question had a very Advanced
case of cancer the machine outputted it
without any trouble and Analysis of the
liquid showed it contained cancer cells
that match the d-class's DNA but another
request for the same spat out and out of
range error what's more a medical
checkup on the d-class revealed that
their tumor was completely gone but
unfortunately it was only a short-term
fix the cancer cells recurred within two
weeks of the test
scp-294 initially just seemed like a
boring magic vending machine but it was
only after the extensive experimentation
that you just saw a shortened log of
that the SCP Foundation was able to
discern its true nature it wasn't an
unthinking object it was sentient
intelligent and even a little sarcastic
though none of that stopped it from
doing its job providing people with a
hot cup of whatever they needed to drink
just make sure you type in your request
very carefully hello I am
scp-426 but I'll probably be more
familiar to you as a toaster I am a
retro style four slice 1750 watt toaster
able to toast bread lead when supplied
with power this isn't often mentioned
but I also have a defrost and reheat
settings when I was first sold I had a
two year warranty and my prior owners
did not live to see the end of it you're
probably wondering why am I being spoken
to by a toaster right now believe me I'd
rather do this any other way but such a
thing is not physically possible with me
whenever you talk about me or write
about me or even think about me you'll
find yourself suddenly shifting to the
first person for example I am you and
you are me do you understand don't worry
if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you'll begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is two months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous of fact she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet in a wall
before switching it on causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her
body and kill her her body caught fire
shortly afterwards next was the older
Mrs Sanderson in much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law sought a
source of electricity she felt the need
to integrate bread into her body
interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be
between eight and nine kilograms the
Elder Mrs Sanderson consumed 10
kilograms of raw bread causing her
stomach to rupture and inducing a
painful death as a result the younger Mr
Sanderson was the next to perish he did
something with me that I would rather
not mention and that the SCP Foundation
thought best to redact suffice to say
the younger Mr Sanderson did not survive
the experience dying of severe blood
loss long before his body was found
police and fire Crews arrived at the
home after the body of the younger Mrs
Sanderson Set Fire to the home luckily
the Elder Mr Sanderson was found alive
though severely malnourished when asked
by police why he hadn't eaten in several
days he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior but was still
waiting for the toast to come out when I
was extracted from the house the police
noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
Precinct and the SCP Foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence Locker the story of the strange
deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in the incident directly were
given Class C amnestics the SCP
Foundation is a curious Bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time
performing experiments and Gathering
data and they saw fit to perform several
experiments on me when I came under
their care for experiment 426-1 a member
of d-class personnel designated
d-426-1 was asked to stand outside my
containment chamber crucially he was not
informed about my Identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even
allowed to establish visual contact with
me he was then asked by the attending
researcher to describe what he thought
might be inside my chamber he replied
with and probably some huge monster
holed up in there that's why you guys
have all over the place right the
d-class did not even seem to realize
that he was speaking about me in the
first person these observations were
documented and I was prepared for
further experimentation the next
experiment was 426-2 I found this test
to be considerably more interesting a
d-class subject was brought into my
containment chamber with several cameras
fixed onto his position however the SCP
Foundation took pains to make sure that
I was permanently out of the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the
view of the cameras at any point during
the experiment the objective here was
simple the foundation wished to better
understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind
the the d-class was subjected to a
period of prolonged isolation with meals
given regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a conversationalist
he spent the first few days loudly
vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the
containment chamber begging to be freed
from the room I felt that this was
somewhat unreasonable on his part there
are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been
locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toes than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to a situation and fell into a
morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
state two weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believed that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the d-class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process one hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment 426-3 the SCP Foundation
seemed eager to discover the parameters
of my anomalous effects and wanted to
know if the effects are only operable
when my body for lack of a better word
is whole a single screw was removed from
me and presented to a d-class that had
no knowledge of my identity and
anomalous effects the foundation
researchers were somewhat concerned when
the d-class referred to it as my screw
this was a rather positive development
for me as they realized that attempting
to destroy me would be a fruitless
Endeavor even the parts Left Behind
would likely have the same effects in
the final recorded experiment the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of
my anomalous effects a d-class subject
was placed in a Cell adjacent to mine
and was to be kept there until my
secondary effects manifested the d-class
remained in the cell for 90 days but the
effects never manifested following the
experiment the d-class was terminated
but researchers seemed relieved to fund
the limits of my anomalous abilities a
researcher appended a note to my file
reading thank God there are some limits
to my effects a lot of us were really
starting to get worried about me after
performing studies into the nature of my
abilities and their limits I was given
the Euclid class this is because while
my effects can be unpredictable their
knowledge of my trades makes me
relatively easy to keep contained and of
course being a toaster I do not have the
required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises I am to
remain sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level 3 and above Personnel are to know
of my presence and particularly of my
properties assigned Personnel are to be
rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if Personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than four
months after their last rotation with me
any Personnel affected by me are to be
given a Class C amnestic and transferred
to a different site so how are you
feeling right now a little warm perhaps
is that a fever or are you feeling like
you could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced piece of bread don't try to
resist too much I know you're going to
love being a toaster just like me the
year was 1975.
it was a warm June evening in South
Carolina and fourteen-year-old Jason
White was ready to prove his medal like
a lot of boys his age it mattered a
great deal to him that his peers saw him
as strong tough and most importantly of
all Brave that's why he was camped out
alone just outside of the junkyard as
the sky went dark above him he'd heard
rumors about the things that went on
inside the junkyard scary things
unnatural things but Jason wasn't about
to let those stories scare him he knew
for a fact that the junkyard had been
abandoned for months if not longer
nobody was in there he'd be fine or at
least that's what he kept telling
himself with the moon high up in the sky
Jason crept into the junkyard using a
flashlight's beam to light his way
behind the towers of busted down cars
and scrap metal he heard a distant but
loud grinding noise was it coming from
one of the warehouses no that's
impossible he thought just his mind
playing tricks on him but curiosity
compelled him to get closer Jason
approached the warehouse and saw that
the big iron door was still a jar his
heart was in his throat as he peered
into the building and saw the impossible
it was a man no a machine cobbled
together from pipes wires and aluminum
it was using a power saw to cut apart
metal on a workbench but it wasn't just
one robot there was movement all around
it jerking and twitching in the shadows
as his flashlight being passed over them
Jason saw the moving living bodies of a
menagerie of metal creatures he screamed
in shock and the robotic denizens of the
warehouse all turned and looked at him
Jason had never felt more afraid in his
life until the humanoid robots still
carrying the power saw turn and began
walking towards him it was waving his
free hand around wildly in what Jason
perceived as some kind of threat letting
out another animal Screech Jace and
turned and ran all the way out of the
junkyard until the sounds of clanking
metal faded out behind him Jason was
scarred for life and in that moment he
vowed never to return to his local
junkyard ever again and this was a wise
choice because not long after that a
very different group would be common
during the junkyard and as fans of this
channel will know they don't take kindly
to Intruders if you've ever been on a
long road trip through a rural part of
the United States you've most likely
seen a few quirky signs and wacky
looking businesses along the way whether
it's a diner with a dinosaur protruding
out of the front a gas station shaped
like a UFO or a particularly weird mural
businesses in the small towns lining the
freeways often have to get creative when
it comes to attracting patrons locations
like this saw their Heyday in the 1950s
and 1960s but as the cost of gasoline
skyrocketed in the 70s and technological
advances in Ava nation made flights more
accessible as a form of travel less and
less people were making long
cross-country drives on a regular basis
this caused an economic downturn in many
small towns and led to a large number of
quirky and unique roadside locations
being abandoned by their owners some
have been torn down or remodeled but
others remain as they were hanging on as
tourist destinations and serving as
reminders of a bygone era one such place
that you might encounter if you ever
find yourself heading down I-95 south is
Jamaica Joe's junkyard Jubilee the
colorful storefront is decorated with a
mural depicting a picturesque tropical
Lagoon while a sign reads one love in
hand-painted green and yellow letters at
first glance this might just seem like
Another Roadside Oddity but if you were
to try and check it out you'd be blocked
by a patrol of six armed guards SCP
Foundation agents of course and
depending on how much you saw you might
be administered an amnestic before being
sent on your way because Jamaica Joe's
isn't just another junkyard it's
scp-100 scp-100 came to the foundation's
attention on November 9 1976. after
tracking a series of rumors about a
mysterious abandoned scrapyard where the
machines ran on their own and strange
metal figures could be seen patrolling
the grounds when the foundation arrived
at the site they installed wooden
privacy screens around the fence of the
junkyard replaced the storefront windows
with one-way glass and redirected the
highway through a nearby town to keep
civilian traffic from getting too close
Jamaican Joe's junkyard Jubilee is 5 000
square meters of fenced off land located
in rural South Carolina as the name
suggests it's a junkyard made up of two
warehouses a storefront a small
residential building and a storage space
containing roughly 1500 vehicles of
varying makes and models some of which
have been compressed into cubes there is
also a variety of other metal scrap on
the site altogether valued to be worth
about five thousand dollars pocket
change to an organization like the SCP
Foundation just like many other cases
where the anomaly cannot be relocated to
a pre-established foundation containment
site for research the SCP Foundation
instead brought the research to the
anomaly the larger of the two warehouses
on site is now the de facto Research
Center for all matters involving scp-100
as well as a temporary residence for
on-site staff it is important to note
that there's nothing anomalous about the
location itself but within the area of
the junkyard are a variety of
euclid-class anomalous entities the
property was at one point owned by a man
by the name of Joseph Duvall presumably
the titular Jamaican Joe however the
whereabouts of Mr Duvall are unknown
Research into local records show that
the utility bills to Mr Duvall's
personal address had stopped around
three months before the junkyard was
found upon the first sweep of location
the foundation found no evidence of
human habitation save for one note taped
to the door of the storefront reading
out to lunch please see assistant JJ the
first anomaly that was cataloged on the
site was scp-100-1 a humanoid automaton
made of scrap metal mainly copper wires
and tin cans
scp-100-1 has a limited degree of
sapience and although it has no means of
verbal or written communication it does
speak through the use of rudimentary
sign language it seems uninterested in
conversation though unless the topic has
to do with the sale of scrap metal the
information the foundation has been able
to learn from scp-100-1 has been limited
but the fact it appears to be mostly
work and very little play is incredibly
clear what it lacks in conversational
skills it makes up four in craftsmanship
scp-100-1 has been shown to be very
Adept at using an arc welder drill power
saw and other Machinery founder around
the junkyard through its metalworking
skills it is able to create more beings
like itself from the scrap that
surrounds it when given the chance
scp-100-1 usually creates automatons
that resemble one of four animal species
Flamingo crocodile turtle or iguana
however it's also able to create metal
copies of other creatures from Bugs to
domestic pet breeds like cats and dogs
while the foundation usually destroys
the new constructs created by scp-100-1
it has been allowed to keep two in order
to keep it Placid and preserve a cordial
working relationship with the foundation
operatives on site these two metal
creatures which both resemble large
metal insects have been designated as
cp100-2-a and
scp-100-2-b though it seems scp-100-1
has named them Ray Monet and Beatrice
respectively based on the fact that
those names are welded into the backs of
the creatures raymonde and Beatrice
fulfill the role of perimeter guards in
as well as companions to scp-100-1
scp-100-1 and its pets are peaceful in
nature and in fact if they ever breach
the perimeter of the junkyard they lose
all autonomy seeming to shut down until
they are brought back within the
perimeter as such containment breaches
are nearly all to come from Outsiders
trying to infiltrate the building rather
than any of the anomalies escaping
scp-100-1's main function seems to be
running the junkyard in the absence of
the mysterious Jamaican Joe Duvall it
spends most of its days sorting scrap
metal building new constructs and
Performing maintenance tasks around the
yard and the robot seems to follow a
very strict ritualistic schedule from 8
AM to 3pm scp-100-1 enters the
storefront area of the junkyard when a
customer enters the shop
scp-100-1 will take its position behind
the front desk and begin bargaining with
them using hand gestures to convey
meaning scp-100-1
possesses the ability to perform the
basic mental arithmetic required to keep
track of sales despite seemingly being
unable to read when scp-100-1 has been
observed making sales to customers the
foundation has found that the robot can
be very underhanded and unfair when it
comes to running its business like a
kind of metallic Mr Krabs frequently it
has been seen intentionally selecting
low quality scrap or using scales that
it knows are faulty in order to scam
customers it also sells the animal
automatons that it creates knowing full
well that they will stop working as soon
as they're taken out of the junkyard in
cases where customers have rightfully
come back to demand refunds
scp-100-1 invariably responds by
gesturing to a sign on the wall which
reads no refunds mom written in a
phonetic Jamaican accent after clocking
out for the day at 3 pm
scp-100-1 spends an hour maintaining and
socializing with Raymond a and Beatrice
it's two insect-like pets it will also
communicate with them through hand
gestures and will engage them in games
of fetch or hide and seek in the
junkyard from 4 pm until 8 PM
scp-100-1 spends its time ticking stock
and cleaning all the tools and Machinery
on the premises it also takes time to
clean both the interiors and exteriors
of the various buildings on the site
then at 8 pm it appears to wind down for
the day with some leisure activities
including making more constructs playing
some more with its pets and taking
strolls around the perimeter of the site
this leisure time lasts until midnight
when scp-100-1 will retire to the
residential part of the junkyard the
robot doesn't need to sleep but it does
seem to rest sitting motionless at a
desk from Midnight until 8 A.M when it
resumes the schedule again from the
beginning this was all that was observed
at scp-100 for decades following its
Discovery
scp-100-1 was seemingly content with its
life and with the tasks that came with
running the junkyard however on June 3
2005
scp-100-1 did something it had never
done before as mentioned
scp-100-1 had only been seen using its
skills to create autonomous animals from
scrap metal but on June 3rd it chose to
create something else another humanoid
the automaton was only 10 centimeters
tall but scp-100-1 took great care in
crafting it much more so than any of its
Creations it gave the small figure
distinct facial features and made the
whole thing from high quality stainless
steel when scp-100-1 was finished with
its creation it welded the letters JJ
onto the back and took it into the
storefront during its 8 AM to 3pm shift
that day
scp-100-1 sat at the desk with JJ on the
desk next to itself and the two seemed
to carry on a conversation through
signing and gestures as was policy with
all of scp-100-1 constructs excluding
Raymond a and Beatrice JJ was
confiscated which scp-100-1 took very
badly following JJ's removal
scp-100-1 returned to the residential
building and stayed there remaining a
nerd for a total of 10 days it is unsure
what really happened to the original
Jamaican Joe or what his precise
relationship was with scp-100-1 given
the difficulty in communicating with
scp-100-1 it is possible that we'll
never know for sure but from what little
were able to glean from the enigmatic
out to lunch please see assistant JJ
note he left behind it's very possible
that before he left Jamaican Joe may
have created the best assistant to
junkyard owner could possibly ask for
hello hello are watching SCP explained
and today we've got an offer you simply
can't refuse the very latest in
anomalous self-improvement technology
which the SCP Foundation calls
scp-212 but we much prefer to call it
the improver believe us when we say this
miraculous device will change your life
you'll never be the same after a run-in
with the improver it'll make you fitter
healthier better not convinced don't
worry just sit back and let us sell you
the dream here's some unpleasant news
you're going to die no matter how
healthy you are right now there will
inevitably come a day when your lungs
stop pumping your ticker stops ticking
and all those delightful little synapses
in your brain stop sending electrical
and chemical signals to and fro what a
bummer why would you want to be dead you
can't do stuff when you're dead and it's
all because everyone is eventually
betrayed by the very things currently
keeping them alive those pesky squishy
failable organs but thanks to the
improver getting stuck with the organs
you were born with is a problem of
yesteryear no matter what those lousy
circus tell you the flesh is unreliable
metal and plastic on the other hand
that's built to last bleeding hearts
talk a lot about quality of life but
what really matters is quantity of life
and if you're strong enough that's what
the improver a state-of-the-art piece of
medical technology will give you don't
look so afraid you replace your phone
every year you replace your laptop every
few years so why get all sentimental
about needing to trade in your old
liverized limbs or skin for the new
model or in the words of another great
businessman why be you when you can be
new not convinced let us tell you about
the incredible features that the
improver has to offer I'm talking three
top of the line fully opposable plastic
and steel autonomous medical limbs
that's industry lingo for robot arms
that work on their own with 500 down on
500 different attachments but I know
what you're thinking 500 attachments
where am I gonna find the room for all
that SCP explained to which we say don't
worry about it due to its specially
anomalous properties the improver is
able to store all these attachments
within its arms without any additional
space concerns and hey I see that
nervous look in your eye you're worried
about the operating costs right but
don't worry there's no need the improver
is completely self-powered with no
discernible power source and you know
the thing is safe because the SCP
Foundation has given it the safe object
class sure that technically doesn't mean
it's not dangerous but it does mean it
won't Sprout legs walk up if you leave
it to your own devices am I right folks
so you're looking at a long-term
investment with the three year warranty
and an endorsement from the fabulous
Folks at the church of the broken God
you just can't argue with these deals my
friends we even offer competitive rights
against Marshall Carter and dark but hey
we're not trying to pull the wool over
your eyes here you're a smart consumer
we know that you know the actual
Financial cost is only one layer of the
overall cost time and training is also
of course a factor but we've got some
good news for you sunshine the improver
is 100
user-friendly no setup No Mess no
problem no trying to interpret poorly
written instructions or watch batted Out
YouTube Tech tutorials where the guy
just will not get to the point the
improver operates itself it may be a
piece of hyper Advanced anomalous
technology but it's easier to use than
most wireless printers am I right am I
right the steps to using the improver
are so simple a monkey could do it just
step within a 1.5 meter range of the
machine and it will do the rest you'll
feel your troubles melt away as the
powerful mechanical arms grab you and
restrain you against the floor you'll be
be subjected to a brief relaxing scan
where the improver will determine
exactly what needs to be changed about
your fragile human physiology and then
before you know it surgery will commence
when SCP explained is not liable for any
excruciating pain caused by the improver
medical sedatives and anesthetics are
sold separately the consumers
responsible for their own pain relief
when using the improver second warning
the consumer is also responsible for
their own blood transfusions when using
the improver neither the improver nor
SCP explained is liable for any blood
loss while using the improver your blood
your problem now with those tiny little
caveats out of the way we carry on
telling you just how fantastic the
improver is sure flesh worshiping
starkist losers and haters will tell you
that it has a mortality rate of around
47 but we prefer to look on the bright
side and focus on its excellent 53
survival rate rest assured the odds are
still very much in your favor when you
use the improver and doesn't adding a
slight risk to the equation just make
the whole process even more exciting we
certainly think it does and in the
reasonably likely event that you survive
using the improver the benefits will
vastly outweigh the costs it can do
incredible things like lining your
joints with graphite replacing your
nasty flesh organs with more powerful
artificial ones adding new or duplicate
organs replacing those unreliable teeth
with serrated steel blades and so much
more is there anything this absolute
Marvel of a machine can't do doctors
hate it the improver is here to fix
every aspect of your life and health
with its simple anomalous tricks it even
has a special sealant for wound closing
that no medical professional on Earth
has access to what is it exactly well if
we told you I'm afraid we'd have to kill
you it's a trade secret
you'd have to be crazy not to want the
improver in your home but if for some
crazy reason you still need to be
convinced let's look at some real
success stories of the improver in
action straight from SCP Foundation
testing logs listen close and soon
you'll see the improver literally makes
satisfied customers the foundation put a
28 year old African-American agent into
the improver of his own volition he
replaced his boring lower Jawbone with a
super dense ceramic jaw with ceramic
blades instead of teeth it also removed
his spine and replaced it with a
synthetic polymer which was easily
affixed to the base of his skull and no
extra charge it even coated his rib cage
and pelvis with a thin layer of ceramic
before removing his lungs eyes and liver
for cleaning and replacement That's
Right cleaning the improver can remove
organs and through a patented cleaning
process remove genetic defects and allow
them to appear younger and healthier
than generic brand X organs this agent
has since returned to active duty and is
even better at his job all thanks to the
improver looking good out there champ a
42 year old British Foundation
researcher was submitted for testing on
the improver it replaced his teeth with
Sleek super dense ceramic reinstated his
inefficient feat and replaced them with
a complex latticework covered in sticky
pads that would let him climb on any
surface and hold up to 225 kilograms of
weight it also took out and cleaned a
huge number of his organs removed his
bone marrow and replaced it with blue
synthetic gel much more effective we
assure you and inserted a few random
bits of metal into his brain at no extra
cost sadly this researcher passed away
during the bone marrow removal process
but for all we know that could easily
just be a coincidence next came an agent
co-named a a who had suffered a pretty
severe accident at work losing all his
limbs one of his eyes a view of his
organs and suffering a pretty dramatic
head injury namely taking a piece of
circuit board to the brain during an
explosion he was given over to the
improvers seeing as he didn't really
have much to lose in terms of physical
Integrity but seeing that it's an
amazing piece of groundbreaking
technology the improver never takes the
obvious option it gave a a chemical that
forced him into a coma and then properly
integrated the circuit board into his
brain it continues to spread and
assimilate more of his brain matter
while he's in a comatose state though
when he awakens with a much more
efficient brain he'll probably be
incredibly grateful to the improver for
helping him like this and it's not just
people with severe injuries that the
improver can lend three helping robotic
hands too it's also the victims of
severe and even anomalous diseases take
victims of scp-217 or rather horrific
significant painful disease that
mechanizes the entire body until the
sufferers aren't really themselves
anymore a normal uninspired SCP
Foundation researcher may look at
someone like this and see a lost cause
but with the help of the improver no
cause is lost a d-class in the advanced
stages of the disease was run through
the machine and while the exact details
of what it did to him are another trade
secret it's safe to say he was truly
fighting fit when he came out on the
other side we mean that literally he
easily escaped containment and
overpowered two heavily armed guards
before taking the lives of several
members of foundation staff before being
captured and terminated sometime later
you can't argue with those incredible
results folks next came a 26 year old
SCP Foundation researcher who due to an
unfortunate brush with a less wonderful
and beneficial anomaly had been rendered
completely blind however when he was
brought into the grasp of the improver
it immediately set to work on solving
the doctor's little problem it removed
his two non-functioning eyes and made
the interesting creative choice of
widening the two cavities in his head so
they met in the middle and formed one
huge cavity for a single large sensory
organ this cavity was then filled with
large metal spikes resembling hair which
are far more interesting than typical
eyes during the improver's delicate
medical procedures the scientists
inexplicably entered a state of visible
distress and began repeating the phrase
it tastes all wrong at this point the
metal cilia in the scientist's single
large cavity began to grow expanding
through the roof of the cavity and into
the subject's brain killing him we want
to specify that SCP explained and the
improver are in no way responsible for
this unfortunate incident it's entirely
the researcher's fault for setting off
his own metal eye cavity cilia before we
bring this anomalous infomercial to an
end and of course before you immediately
grab your credit card and buy your own
improver device we want to sneak a few
more disclaimers under the wire for
starters the improver doesn't work on
animals when a rat was used as a test
subject the device attempted to modify
the rat into a bipedal being removing
the majority of organs are replacing it
with white paste so if your pet rat gets
sick just uh take her to the vet instead
the improver also doesn't work on
corpses it may be a miraculous piece of
technology but uh it's not a literal
Miracle Worker folks one freshly
executed d-class was presented to the
improver and instead of operating on him
the improver cut open his stomach and
instead began constructing something out
of metal he had consumed the night prior
to his death a seafood dinner the broken
crustacean pots were then constructed
into a bioluminescent lobster-like
creature so if you're planning on
bringing someone back from the dead
we're afraid you're going to need to
take up necromancy instead but if you
haven't died yet and you're looking to
improve yourself then you cannot invest
in a better product than the improver
the one problem is that the only known
prototype of the improver is currently
locked in an SCP Foundation containment
site so getting your hands on these
three special arms May cost you your
life what who said attaining Perfection
would be easy did hear that not so long
ago a five-year-old boy went up against
12 of Russia's greatest chess Grand
Masters and do you know what happened he
lost every single match that's because
winning a chest dear viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversary's moves before they've even
been made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be queen scambit level
chess prodigies Eric Matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was Brian
Matthews his father you see for as long
as Eric could remember his dad had
regarded a high level of skill on the
chat chessboard to be a sign of
intellectual superiority intelligence
was something that Brian put quite a
considerable value on given that he was
a professor at a university in their
home country of England some of Eric's
earliest memories were of playing chess
with his dad usually on a Friday night
when Brian got home after a week of
giving lectures to the next generation
of Scholars obviously with his son at
such a young age the professor would
take it easy on Eric playing in a much
laxer fashion focusing instead on
teaching the boy the basics of the game
and for a time at least it was good it
was a rare time that Eric and his
academic father could spend bonding
after all with his mother gone his dad
was all he had but as the years passed
the game Changed by the time Eric was a
teenager Brian had stopped pulling his
punches on the chessboard he hoped his
son would build on what he'd learned
when they played in the past using those
skills to best his dad on the board but
to Eric playing chess had never been
about a purely educational experience it
was more about spending time with his
old man Time After Time the young man's
pawns fell prey to Brian's expertly
considered and far more competitive
moves try as he might Eric couldn't best
his dad he tried his best and never
stopped putting the effort into every
game but thinking too hard about one
possible plan of attack left him wide
open to a counter strategy from the
professor over and over again he landed
himself in Checkmate or made illegal
moves without even realizing it every
time earning criticism and chastise men
from his scholarly father every game had
got worse it was like Eric could feel
his father's gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he
made across the board there were so many
nights where he wondered if it would be
better to give up entirely to knock down
his own King and concede but how could
he ever find any other shared interests
with his dad beyond the two of them
playing chess it had become a Lifeline
tethering Father and Son together and to
cut it now left Eric uncertain if he'd
sink or be able to swim alongside Brian
he had long admired his father his
achievements in Academia were impossible
to avoid with more frames certificates
hung up on the walls than there were
photos of the pair of them together but
the shadow would cast over him made Eric
desperate to keep this one shred of
Common Ground alive Eric wasn't the type
to give up despite how much of an uphill
struggled the situation felt like taking
a leaf out of his Professor father's
scholarly ways he decided to learn the
game inside and out every known move and
strategy he would research the entire
history of Chess itself if that's what
it took to play with the same skill as
his dear old dad over the coming weeks
Eric checked out every book at his local
library on the subject beginner's guides
Advanced rule books and even a few
volumes on notable players throughout
the extensively long history of the game
along the way a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric it described a
chess Prodigy from Russia who had
created an early mechanical chest device
known as the samurai it had been
designed to be a traveling curiosity and
would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating
audience each one of them having forked
over some of their hard-earned money to
watch this man-made wonder the Russian
chess Prodigy's young daughters also had
a love for the game seeing that gave
Eric a Pang of jealousy wondering if
those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with
Brian but at least there was an
underlying shred of Hope there too if
this father and his daughters could bond
over chess maybe there was a chance for
Eric and his dad too sadly it's one
thing to try and learn all the facts you
can about Chess it's an entirely
different Beast to put all that
information to use and apply it to an
actual game despite having read every
book he could get his hands on Eric
still couldn't best Brian at the board
it was like nothing had changed his
father barely noticed when Eric tried to
replicate movesets he'd read up on and
still managed to not only counter those
moves but check his Queen in the process
so practice Eric thought after all
practice was supposedly meant to make
perfect right the plan was simple if he
practices chess moves enough times and
figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this plan Eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was Brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop Eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of sub-level maybe used as
a basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an at-home
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early 90s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was at first the thing
was some kind of bizarre Contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that Eric recognized All Too
Well a chess table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer well
back in the 90s computers were hardly as
commonplace as they are now Eric had
seen a fair few at school tool and the
library although this one was different
it seemed old far older than Eric
thought computers had been around for as
far as he knew they'd only really come
to prominence in the mid 80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by modsley sons
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seem that this whole
device had been around since the
Victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the chess pieces themselves
each one standing neatly in its place on
the board they looked delicate
intricately carved from some smooth
substance for a moment Eric toyed with
the thought of how they could even be
made from bone noticing how each Pawn
Knight Rook Bishop king and queen were
all about the size of a human finger
bone he dismissed the idea nobody would
ever do something like that
foreign
grabbed a sheet covering a large
component hooked up to the mess lifting
it away in a swift pole it unveiled what
was sitting beneath a full Suite of 18th
century Samurai armor Eric looked closer
at the embellishments on the surface of
the pauldrons he was no expert on feudal
Japan but it looked authentic enough to
be the real thing if not a very close
approximation taking a look at the
collection of oddities all tethered
together in his father's lab a certain
detail of all his chess research came to
the Forefront of Eric's mind the armor
that had given it away this was the
samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owned such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Rush chess Prodigy was this
machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess would using it give him the edge
he needed to best him at the game and
earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of sophisticated mechanism
that was within the suit of Samurai
armor allowing it to move in what
appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chess
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite Eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against Samurai but because
of the speed he'd set it to determining
that the settings might have correlated
to difficulty levels Eric figured that
if he really wanted to get the most
rigorous practice to really hone his
chest moves he needed to commit fully
reaching for the dial he turned the
device up to its Fifth and highest speed
then made his first move he pushed one
of the bone-colored prawns forward by a
single square and waited a split second
passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead everywhere and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruelly knocked over one of his Pieces
away Eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it he kept
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine's moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
saved for a night a rook his king and
queen but he had won trapped without
anywhere else to move on the board the
middle finger of the automaton conceded
the Game knocking over its own King and
resignation panting heart racing from
the sheer excitement of being on The
Winning Side of A game Eric Hurley
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chess machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it seemed Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
but things started to change maybe it
was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer the natural
wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernible strategy behind them then
its movements became flat out illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the days
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when when he
returned home looking noticeably under
the weather confused Eric said that he
had no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named shakhmadi a
word in Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 1990s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on right
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches in a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just speed of fatigue
after a long day of teaching at the
University no cause for concern if only
that's all it was within a few hours
Brian was completely restless so unable
to sleep that simply taking a nap was
impossible he kept calling to Eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down Eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
Brian had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the Warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now Eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for a
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize Brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes opened
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to Eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space Eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
Brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
Lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work I I need to
get on my computer Ryan demanded of his
son when Eric refused that's when his
dad got angry and agitated Professor
Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months several
months later as the sole executor of his
father's estate and last living relative
Eric had to be the one to go through his
dad's personal belongings volumes upon
volumes of thick academic books his
smart scholarly clothes the house was
almost clear now save for one thing that
was left in the basement lab flicking on
the light switch Eric looked at the
samurai sitting motionless still
uncovered after their last practice game
he'd sold off the chess pieces to a
collector in New York now it was just an
empty Oddity Eric placed a king on the
board one of the ones that he and his
dad had used when they played each other
with a gentle flick of his finger he
toppled it resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the
laboratory he wasn't sure how but he had
some kind of gut feeling that this chess
machine had somehow been responsible for
his father's fate of course Eric had no
idea what the device actually was and
what or who lay beneath its worrying
metal Parts
scp-1875 is the designation given to
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine deep
within the heart of this early form of
computer the two girls brain tissue had
been hooked up to the electromagnets the
machines moves were theirs each Pawn or
Rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he'd carved into chess pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on
scp-1875 playing multiple games of Chess
against it every time they increase the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on
scp-1875 received a bizarre email it
contained a file named with the Russian
word for chess and a photograph of the
stretched distorted smiling and
screaming faces of two young girls faces
that you might be seeing very soon now
go and check out
scp-1733 season opener and scp-1984 the
dead hand if you're in the mood for more
Tales of technological Terrors and other
chaos spreading computerized creatures